if you already work with data in excel
and want to add more power to your data
analysis and evaluation using python
then this is the course for you frank is
a data scientist and he will teach you
how to use python to work with data hi
everyone my name is frank andrade and
this is my python course for excel users
i created this course to help excel
users move from excel to python but why
python well in python we can do most of
the things we will do in excel such as
working with data making charts and
pivot tables but that's not all we can
use all the power of python to automate
tasks work with large data and do a lot
of things thanks to the thousands of
free libraries python has on top of that
python can help you become a better data
analyst or get into new fields like data
science i divided this python course for
excel users in three modules in module
one i'll teach you all the python core
concepts you need to know for that
analysis then in module two we'll learn
pandas pandas is a python data analysis
library that will help us do most of the
things we can do on excel in module 3
we'll put into practice what we learned
in this course by creating a pivot table
and visualizations such as line plots
bar plots and pie charts remember that
in the description you will find the
files code as well as a free pdf python
cheat sheet i created for this course
there you will find the concepts methods
and functions we will see in this course
by the way i'm frank and i will be your
instructor in this course so let's get
started
to download anaconda we go to
anaconda.com and click on get started
then we choose the last option download
anacond installers and then we have
here the different anaconda installers
so there are windows mac and linux so in
my case i'm gonna choose mac and i'm
gonna choose that 64-bit graphical
installer so now i'm downloading
anaconda and once it's
downloaded i'm gonna click on it
and a message will pop up you just have
to click on allow as i'm gonna do right
now so just click on allow and then
click on continue until the installation
starts so i just click continue and then
agree and then continue and it's going
to start installing anaconda in case
you're on windows and you're installing
python or anaconda for the first time
make sure to check the first box you see
now on screen so i'm gonna speed up the
video now okay the installation is
almost done and now it's telling me that
anaconda works with pycharm and now i'm
just going to click on continue
to finish the installation so i click on
continue and then we'll see just a
summary of what was installed and now
i'm gonna close this window and i'm
gonna open anaconda so i'm going to
locate the icon it's a green icon
this one that you see here
and i'm gonna open anaconda i'm gonna
wait a couple of seconds and let's see
what was installed so here we have the
jupiter lab and jupiter notebook which
are
widely used in data science so i'm going
to launch jupiter notebook so here it's
opening jupiter notebook let's give it a
second and now we open a new notebook
with python 3 so
python 3 was installed too and that's it
in the following videos we'll learn how
to use jupyter notebook
in this video i will introduce you to
the jupiter notebook interface jupiter
notebook is an open source web
application that allows us to create and
share documents that contain live code
equations visualizations
and text this is a perfect text editor
for doing data cleaning and
transformation data visualization and
data analysis this is why jupyter
notebook is widely used in data science
and also machine learning as you might
remember we installed jupyter notebook
and python with the anaconda navigator
and this means that we already have
installed some popular libraries used in
python for data analysis by the way one
of the alternatives of jupyter notebook
is jupiter lab both are similar but
we're going to use jupyter notebook in
this course because of its simplicity so
let's open jupyter notebook and to do
that we have to click here on the launch
button so i click here
now we wait a couple of seconds and now
we have here the interface of jupyter
notebook so i'm gonna maximize this and
by default jupyter notebook opens the
root directory of your computer it's a
good idea to create a folder where all
your python scripts will be located in
my case this folder is called anacond
scripts so i click here and now i can
navigate through the folders and the
folder i'm gonna use for this example is
this one that says my course and here
we're gonna create our first python
script to do that we click here on the
new button so click here and we have to
click on the first option that says
python3 there are other options like
text file folder or the terminal but we
are not going to use these options in
this course so click on python 3
and now we have a python script powered
by jupyter notebook so here on the right
you can see that it says python3 and
also there is the python logo and on the
left you can see here the jupyter
notebook logo and also the name of this
jupiter notebook file we can change the
name of the file by clicking here on
untitled so i click here and i can
change it to
let's say example so i write example and
i click on rename and now we renamed
this
jupyter notebook file all right now
let's navigate through this menu bar
that we have here in this jupyter
notebook file so the first option is the
file and here we can create a new
notebook with python3 so if we click
here we're going to open a new jupyter
notebook file from scratch as we did
before
then we have that open and in this case
we can open a jupyter notebook we
created before we can also make a copy
to a jupyter notebook and then change
the name we can save a jupyter notebook
file and rename the file as we did
before we only click here and rename the
file then we can save all the progress
we make in jupiter notebook for example
after writing many lines of code you can
save all the progress you make by
pressing ctrl s or command s on mac and
you're going to create a checkpoint and
later you can revert to a previous
checkpoint by using this option here so
here you will see many checkpoints and
you can revert to a previous checkpoint
by the way by default jupyter notebook
makes saves every 30 seconds or maybe
one minute so there is no need to
press ctrl s every time so keep that in
mind then we have other options that i
don't use so much like print this
jupyter notebook or export that jupiter
notebook file to html or pdf and so on
okay now let's see the second option
that says edit and here we can edit all
the cells we have here in this jupyter
notebook by the way here what you see
here on the screen is a cell
so we can edit with this edit option for
example we can cut sales we can copy
sales page sales above and delete sales
on the right you can see the shortcuts
that we're going to see on the next
video in detail and well you can check
all the
edit options that you can perform on
jupyter notebook here then in the view
option we can toggle the header the
toolbar and also
line numbers so here if i click on
toggle header the header is going to
disappear and if i click on toggle
toolbar this toolbar disappears too
also here in toggle line numbers we can
show here line numbers so if i
write anything we can see that it says 1
2 3 and so on
and i'm not going to use this for this
course i'm going to leave it with the
default option so here i'm gonna revert
to the original option so without line
numbers and i want to show the header
and also the toolbar but you can
personalize it as you want next in the
insert options we can insert cells above
or below we only click here and well
we're gonna see the shortcuts later in
the next video
then we have the cell options we can run
cells or run all the cells in this
jupyter notebook file and then we have
the kernel option and a kernel is a
computational engine that executes the
code contained in a notebook document
when we open jupyter notebook a kernel
is automatically launched and we can
interrupt this kernel by clicking here
so by interrupting we can pause the
execution of a code we can also restart
everything and do more things here
sometimes for example i interrupt the
kernel when
a line of code or a cell takes too much
time to execute
and well you can do the same here with
restart or interrupt
then we have the navigate option that
doesn't actually have anything here
widgets that i don't use so much and
will help that i think it will send you
to that documentation of jupyter
notebook and you can read it if you want
all right here then we have the toolbar
and here you will find some shortcuts of
the
menu bar that we've seen before for
example here you can save and make a
checkpoint
so here i click here and as you can see
here it says checkpoint created or
something like that yeah checkpoint
created and the time that it was created
then you can
here with this plus button insert a cell
below so i click here and as you can see
we can insert a cell below and also you
can use shortcuts but that i'm going to
show you in the next video
then we can cut selected cells with this
button
we can copy a cell with this button and
also we can paste
cells below also we can move a cell
above or below for example i'm going to
write anything here in this cell i can
move it above with this button or below
as you can see here then we can run this
code for example i can write the number
one and then run the code and as you can
see here the code ran and it shows the
number one and well those are some of
the frequently used buttons in the
toolbar and that's everything you need
to know about this jupyter notebook file
okay now before finishing this video i'm
going to show you some other options
that you can find here in the jupyter
notebook interface and here you can see
that there are some other options so
right now we are in the files tab
and we can change to the running tab
here
and here you can see all the currently
running jupyter notebook processes for
example we can see here the jupyter
notebook file we created and that we
opened so you can recognize that a
jupyter notebook file is open or that is
running because here the icon will be in
green so here if we go back to the files
tab we can see that this jupyter
notebook file which by the way has the
ipy and b extension is in green so the
icon is in green so this indicates that
the file is running and well it was
opened
so here we can see that is open and we
can shut down this file and this is
different from closing this file for
example here i have the file and if i
close this file
here we can see that the
file is still running here we see
running and is in green and in the
running tab it still shows up so if we
want to shut down this file we click
here and it says that there are no
notebooks running and we can see here
that the notebook has a great icon all
right then we have the clusters tab and
this tab i don't use so much and
actually it doesn't show anything here
and then we have the nb extensions tab
here you can install any extension to
personalize jupyter notebook even more
and we're gonna see some cool jupyter
notebook extensions in the next videos
and by the way this nb extensions tab
doesn't show up in some versions of
jupyter notebook but we can easily
install it and we'll also see how to
install this nb extensions tab in the
next videos finally we have this box
that shows our directory so here this
folder indicates the root directory so
if i click here we are not in the root
and if i click on the folders anaconda
script and then my course i go to the
folder where i was before and that's it
these are all the things you need to
know about the jupyter notebook
interface
okay in this video we're gonna see some
cell types and cell modes in jupiter
notebook so first we're gonna open the
jupyter notebook file that we created in
the previous video which is this one
example.ipynb
so we click on it and here we have the
jupyter notebook file opened and here by
default we have this for result in
command mode and we can say that this is
command mode because here this blue
color indicates that the cell is in
command mode and when we are in command
mode we can do things outside the scope
of any individual cell so basically all
the tools we see here in the
toolbar we can apply it in command mode
also in command mode we can apply some
shortcuts that i'm going to show you
later and for example if we want to see
the shortcut window we press the
letter h in command mode and we can see
the keyboard shortcuts here
so here you can see all the shortcuts
and all the shortcuts that you can apply
in command mode now i'm going to close
this one
and also you can apply different
shortcuts like for example if you press
b in the command mode you will see that
there is a new cell because b is the
shortcut that introduces a new cell
below now if we press enter you're gonna
see that the color is gonna change to
green so here we have green color and
this green color indicates that we are
in edit mode and the edit mode is for
all the actions you will usually perform
in the context of the cell
for example introducing text or writing
code so here i can write say one two
three so if i write one two three and
then i click on this run button i'm
gonna run this cell and as you can see
here i run this first cell and also
after running the cell you can see that
we are again in command mode so to go to
edit mode we press enter again and now
we can edit the numbers we introduce so
for example i can write 4 five six and
then run again and here you can see that
the output shows one two three four five
and six by the way if you try to use the
shortcut in edit mode it won't work here
i press enter and now i'm on edit mode
and if i press the letter h
you can see that nothing happens we
don't have the shortcut window and if i
press the letter b you can see that we
don't insert any
cell below this happens because those
shortcuts work only on command mode so
to escape this edit mode we have to
press the escape button so i press
escape and now i'm again in command mode
so if i press h we have here the
keyboard shortcut and if i press b
you can see that we inserted a new cell
and that's it for the command in the
edit mode now we'll see the cell types
in jupiter notebook in jupiter notebook
there are three main cell types and we
can see all of them in this drop down
here right now the type of this cell is
code so here it says code but if we
press here you can see other cell types
like markdown and row and b convert so
we're gonna see first the code cell and
it already has the check so this one is
a code cell so now i press here and now
well it's in code cell if i press enter
i'm in edit mode and here i can
introduce any code i want so here i can
write uh any number 999 and if i press
ctrl enter we can see that here this is
the input and here we got the output of
this code we're going to see how the
code cell works throughout this course
but now it's time to see how the
markdown cell works in jupyter notebook
so here i'm going to this cell and now
i'm going to change the cell type so i
press here in the drop down and now i
select markdown in the markdown cell we
can introduce any type of text we want
for example we can introduce titles so
if i uh delete this and press
the hash sign we can get title so one
hash it means title so here i press
space and now i write title now i press
ctrl enter or this run button to run
this cell
and here we got the title by the way you
shouldn't get this one number because i
just modified the default behavior of
jupyter notebook so mine enumerates the
titles and subtitles but in your case
you will see only the word title and if
you want you can introduce also
subtitles here so for example i'm gonna
insert a new cell with this button this
plus button and now i'm gonna move this
cell up with this button here so i press
this and now i'm going to change the
cell type from code cell to markdown
cell so i go to the drop down and select
markdown
and by the way you can change the cell
type also with shortcuts so if you're in
command mode you can press the
y button to change the code cell so i
press the y button and as you can see
here it says in and this in with the
square brackets indicates that this is a
code cell so here i can press enter and
introduce any code here i introduce
numbers and press the run button and
here you can see that we have an input
and an output so this is a code cell but
now we can press the m button to make
this cell a markdown cell so now we
press m and here we are in command mode
so now we can get this markdown cell and
here you don't see the in world with the
square brackets anymore so now i'm going
to edit mode so i just press here or
well you can press enter to
go to edit mode and now to introduce a
subtitle i'm gonna write double hash
sign so i press
hash sign twice now space and now i'm
gonna write the subtitle so i write
subtitle i press ctrl enter or the run
button to run this cell and we got here
the subtitle
and we can also introduce text i'm going
to introduce a new cell with a plus
button and you can also do it with a b
shortcut so i'm going to do it with a b
shortcut right now i press b
and here i got this new cell and we can
move this with this button here and now
we have this cell in the position we
want it so here i can introduce text by
converting this cell to markdown so here
i choose markdown now you press enter to
go to edit mode and here i can introduce
any text for example i can write hello
i press ctrl enter and now we can see
that we have here this text and finally
the last type of cell is the row and b
convert and this type of cell is not
evaluated by the notebook kernel so if
we convert this code cell to a row cell
this cell won't be evaluated by the
notebook kernel so let's try here i
press row
and we convert
now we can see that this looks like a
plain cell and well this type of cell is
not used that often actually we're going
to use only that code cell and a
markdown cell in this course and that's
it in this video you'll learn the cell
types and cell modes in jupyter notebook
okay in this video we're gonna see some
common shortcuts used in jupyter
notebook and we're gonna start with the
f shortcut and by the way to use these
shortcuts you have to make sure you're
in the command mode and to verify during
the command mode make sure that the cell
has this blue color
okay now that you're in the command mode
you can press the letter f and you're
gonna see this find and replace so this
first shortcut allows us to find a word
in a cell and then replace it with
another word for example i can write
here the word hello
and here it found the word hello inside
this hello world sentence and now i can
replace this word with the word say hi
for example
so here i write hi
and now and red we can see the match and
in green we can see the word that we're
going to insert so here
let's click on replace all
and now you can see that it doesn't say
hello world anymore but now it says
hi world so now i press ctrl enter which
is another shortcut to run the cell so
you can press here on run or only press
ctrl enter to run this cell so i press
ctrl enter and now we run this cell and
another way to run cells is to press
shift enter but in this case we're going
to run and insert a new cell below so
now let's see i press shift enter and
now here it ran this cell because now it
says in and three inside square brackets
and here we can see that we have a new
cell okay now another shortcut that is
often used is the y and m shortcut so
now this cell is a code cell and if we
want to make this a markdown cell we
only have to press the m letter so we
press m and this is going to be
converted to a markdown cell
and if we press the letter y this is
going to be converted to a code cell and
also you can change the heading here you
can make the heading bigger or smaller
so here i'm going to locate this cell
and now to make this one smaller we can
press the numbers so if we press the
number two we can see that this one gets
smaller and if i press number three the
title gets
smaller for smaller and so on so as you
can see the more hash size the smaller
the text so here i'm going to delete
these hash signs and one hash sign
represents the biggest font size which
is the title so now i press ctrl enter
and now we have this in heading one but
if i press number five and then press
ctrl enter we can see that now this cell
has heading five and it's smaller so now
i'm gonna revert to heading one so i
press 1 and then ctrl enter okay now we
can navigate through the cells by
pressing on the up or down keys on our
keyboard and as you can see here we can
navigate through all the
cells here or we can also press with the
mouse we can press on the cells we want
okay now we can insert a new cell above
by pressing the a key so if i press a
we get here a new cell above and if i
press now
b
we get a new cell below now if i press x
we're going to cut this cell so i press
x and you can see that the cell was cat
and now if we press v we paste that cell
below so i press v and now we got this
cell and if i press shift plus v we get
the cell pasted above so i press shift
and v and we get this new cell above
this cell i have here okay now i can
delete cells by pressing d twice so i
press d two times and as you can see
here the title disappear so now i try it
again and we don't have the title
anymore but now if we press the letter z
we can undo those changes so let's undo
what we did before i press z and we get
here the title back okay another juice
for shortcut is that control s that
allows us to save the changes we made in
this jupyter notebook file so i press
ctrl s and you can see here that says
checkpoint created so i'm going to press
again control s and here it says
checkpoint created and here also says
the time and that's it these are some of
the most common shortcuts used in
jupiter notebook but you can see other
shortcuts by pressing the letter h so i
press h and here you can see more
keyboard shortcuts or you can also go
here to help and then go to keyboard
shortcuts here and you get the same
window so here you can see a list of
shortcuts for command mode and also for
the edit mode you can see the
description of a shortcut and also how
to do it in your operating system
one of the typical ways to get started
with a programming language like python
is printing a simple message you can
write any message you want but it's
traditional among coders to start with a
hello world so let's try it let's print
our first message using the print
function the print function prints a
message to the screen
so i'm gonna write here
print
and then i'm gonna open parentheses
every time we use a function in python
we have to open parenthesis well in this
case for the print function and as you
can see here the functions get a green
color in jupyter notebook so that's how
you can identify them so inside this
parenthesis i'm going to write the
message so in this case it's going to be
hello
world
so this is our first message now to
execute this first line of code we have
to press
ctrl and enter or command and enter if
you're on mac so i'm going to press this
and as you can see here
we have our first hello world another
way to run this first cell is pressing
here on the run button it's going to
have that same effect so i pressed and
it ran
so as you can see here it says in which
it represents a code cell and this is a
markdown cell as we've seen before one
of the advantages that jupiter notebook
has is that it allows us to print the
last object in a code cell without
specifying the print function so for
example here i can print this hello
world with without uh writing this print
function so i'm going to copy this hello
world message that it's uh inside quotes
and i'm gonna run this code so just
control enter and as you can see here we
have this message printed so this is one
of the advantages that has jupiter
notebook if you do this in another
python ide it won't work so here you can
try yourself you can write any message
you want apart from the first hello
world you can try with your name so we
write print then parentheses and we open
quotes because we need to define a
string i'm gonna tell you about strings
a little bit later but just so you know
right now and here for example i can
write my name so my name is frank and i
can print my name
then i can print also numbers so i print
my age 26 and it's gonna work too and
besides writing code you can also add
comments comments are a useful way to
describe what we're doing in our code so
here
we can use comments we just have to
write the hash sign which is this one so
you write hash sign and then you write
the comment in this case i'm gonna write
my
name
and i'm going to say printing my name so
we know what our code is doing here in
the first message we wrote we can also
add a comment so we write hash sign and
then we can save printing my
first message as you can see here the
comments also have a different color so
so far we have three colors this color
for the
comments uh green color for the
functions and red color for the string
this is just a useful functionality most
text editor have that allows us easily
read code
okay now let's see some data types in
python
every value in python is an object an
object has different data types let's
see the most common data types in python
so
one of the most common data types in
python are integer and floats both are
numbers but integers are numbers that
can be written without a fractional
component just like for example the
number 1
number 2 three four five and so on so
all of them are integers and we can
check this value or this data type by
using the type function so this is our
second
function we're going to see so we write
type then parenthesis
and we execute we run this
code and as you can see here in the
output it says
i n t which represents integer so this
is an integer
okay the second type of data i want to
show you is float floats are numbers
that contain floating decimal points so
basically uh
2.3 let's say 1.2
fine
5.4
and so on so
here we have another type of data and
let's check out if these are
actually floats so we use type and then
parentheses and we run this code and we
see that we have float and just like on
excel you can perform math operations in
python using these numbers so some
operations you can use are
addition for example you can say one
plus two and then execute this code and
you get three
you can
use uh subtraction so four minus one
execute and
you run this code and you get three you
can also do multiplication division
exponent and more in python but now
let's see the third data type that we
will see often on python and it's the
boolean boolean are true or false values
and we can check this using again the
type function and we write type and
within parentheses we write for example
true
and
we run this code and we see that
we got that bool which represents a
boolean data type so we can also
write
type and in this case false
and run this code and we get bull again
so this is boolean and we're gonna use
boolean often when we use conditionals
okay now the fourth data type i want to
show you and it's very common is the
string
a string represents a series of
characters and in python anything inside
quotes either single quotes or double
quotes
is a string so let's see them actually
we already see
one kind of string here when we printed
this hello world and you're actually
familiar with this but we're gonna see
it again so
to create a string we have to open
either single or double quotes so in
this case i'm gonna use double quotes so
you see it now
and now i'm gonna write any message so
i'm gonna write for example again uh
hello world and again to verify the type
we can use the type function
parenthesis run this code and we get the
str that represents a string
and one cool thing a string has is
methods we can apply different functions
to strings as we will do
in microsoft excel for example however
in python we use methods a method is a
function that belongs to an object to
call a method we use the dot sign
after the object let's see some string
methods to change the case of a text so
here i'm gonna
write again hello world but now i'm
gonna use some string methods so i write
hello world in this case i'm gonna use
the upper
method to
make this uppercase so i'm going to use
the print function but actually we don't
need to use the print function because
as i told you before
in jupyter notebook we don't need to
use the print because it automatically
prints the last line of code so since
this is the only
uh line of code in this cell block it's
gonna print it automatically so we just
run this uh cell and we have hello world
in upper case so as you might expect now
we can also
change the case of the text in this case
it can be on lower case or tidal case so
i'm gonna
just
copy and paste this twice
and here
i'm gonna write instead of upper
i'm gonna use flower
and then title
so
you can see how it's gonna change the
case
so here i'm gonna run and let's see what
happens
so as you can see here it only printed
the last one uh because as i told you
before it only prints the last one and
if we want to print the three of them
we have two options so we can
maybe here cut and paste on each cell
or what we can do is to print
each of them so here for example i can
do print here and i can do the same for
them so instead of
using more cells we can print all of
them
and here
we can print this one too
actually we don't need that we don't
need it because it's gonna print the
last line but just for the sake of this
video i'm gonna print the three of them
so here i'm gonna
run this code and as you can see here
the first it has an upper case
the second has lower case
and the third has a title case so
that's how you do it on python other
string method that you can find python
is the count method so i'm gonna delete
this and actually this one too and we're
gonna see this now so first i copy this
and now i paste it here
and
here i'm going to use the count so the
count
method so i write count
and then here i open
single quotes and i write
the letter that we want to count so here
for example i'm going to write the l
letter and what this
string method is going to do it's going
gonna count how many times this
l
letter is included in this string so as
we can see there are two else so it
should set
two times so i run this code and
actually is three because there are two
in hello and one in world so i was wrong
and here
uh another string method that you can
use is the replace method so we can
replace one letter for another
so here let me copy this
and i'm gonna paste it here
and instead of writing count i can write
replaced so
here the first
letter that we're going to see here is
the letter that we want to replace
so in this case i'm going to change the
l
with o
and the second letter is the letter that
you want to put in that string so
i'm gonna use the u so i'm gonna change
every time that
an o
appears here in the string we're gonna
replace it for a u vowel so let's try so
i run this code
and now it says well hello world but
with you and these are some of the most
common string methods in python
okay now it's time to learn something
that you're gonna see often in python
which are variables variables help us
store data values in python we often
work with data so variables are useful
to manage this data properly a variable
contains a value which is the
information associated with a variable
to assign a value to a variable we use
that equal sign so let's create a
message that says i'm learning python
and store it in a variable called
message underscore one so here i write
message
underscore one and we set it to the
string i'm learning python so i open
double quotes in here i write um
learning python so this is string we've
seen this before
and this is the variable and we assign
this value to the variable using the
equal sign now i'm going to run this and
as you can see nothing happens
but actually we just assigned that
string to the variable message
underscore one
now if we want to obtain the message i'm
learning python we only have to type the
variable name
and then execute that code so i'm gonna
copy and paste it here and then we run
this code
and as you can see by running this cell
we obtain the content inside the
variable message underscore one we can
create as many variables as we want just
make sure to assign different names to
new variables so let's create a new
message that says and it's fine and
store it in a variable called message
underscore 2. so first i write message
so message
and
underscore
two and then we
set this equal to
uh open double quotes and write and it's
fun this is my second variable and i'm
gonna run this
cell so as we can see the string was
assigned to this second variable and if
i
copy and paste this
variable here and run this code we can
see that the message it's there
by the way if you're using
single quotes instead of double quotes
as i'm using in this video probably you
have the following
uh issue so here i'm gonna copy this one
and paste it here so you can see what
i'm talking about
so let's see your let's say you're using
single quotes instead of double quotes
so you get this this is a problem that
you will have when using single quotes
because in the english language we use
these apostrophes often
so and simple way to deal with this is
using double quotes so as you can see
here if i use double quotes everything
is okay
everything remains as
a string but with single quotes uh it
doesn't happen so only the i
gets this string but the rest it doesn't
get a string value or the string data
type so just make sure you use double
quotes every time you have this
apostrophes and that's it okay now let's
put these two messages together so
message one with message two i wanna put
them together so this is called a string
concatenation
if we want to put message 1 and message
2 together we can use the plus operator
and we can just
do this so i'm going to copy message one
or the variable message one
and now i'm gonna copy the variable
message underscore two
and i use the plus in the middle to
concatenate this
first message with this second message
so i run and let's see what happens
so here we can see that the two messages
were uh concatenated but here there
isn't a space between these two messages
so this is the first message and this is
the second
and there isn't any blank space in the
middle so what we can do here
is to just uh add a blank space so i'm
gonna copy this one and paste it here
and show you
how to do it so here i add a new plus
operator and in the middle we open a
string so
with single quotes or double quotes in
this case i'm going to use single quotes
here
and to create this blank space i'm going
to press a space
and here we have our blank space here
and then we run this code
and now let's see and here as we can see
there is a space so between python and
and we have this blank space and if we
want we can assign this new message to a
new variable so
i'm gonna assign this to a variable
called message and i write message here
and
i
include here below the code
and here i can print this so as you can
see if i run this we can see that the
message is there okay now let me show
you an alternative way to
join
two strings so this is called the f
string and it works like this you write
f and you open a string so we write uh
single quotes here so
one and two and here as you can see
the whole uh
the whole thing is
red so it's like everything is a string
in here inside we can write the message
so let's see uh let's say we write i
don't know a simple hello world so hello
world and we run this and as you can see
here this is a string it just has this f
uh in front of that string
and here uh one of the advantages that
this f string has is that it can have
variables inside the string so here for
example we can write a variable opening
these curly braces so these correlations
can have variables inside it so here i
can write
message underscore one and we can print
it so
if we print we have this string i'm
learning python and now if we want to
concatenate this first message with our
second message we just
have to
include curly braces again
i put it here
and now
i write message two and between
message one and message two i just have
to press space and we have this
so i'm learning python and it's fun so
here we just press space and the space
also appears here so for example if we
add some random text let's say abc we
get this abc between python in between
and so this is how f string works you
just have to write the f then open
single quotes and inside you can write
any message and to include any variable
just you have to open these curly braces
write the variable name and that's how
you join strings
okay now it's time to see a data type
that is used often in data analysis i'm
talking about lists in python lists are
used to store multiple items in a single
variable lists are order and mutable
containers
in python we call mutable to objects
that can change their values
that is elements within a list can
change their values
to create a list we have to introduce
the element inside square brackets
separated by commas so let's create our
first list first we have to set the name
of the list in this case i'm going to
name it countries
and now to create the list we have to
open square brackets as i said before so
here
we open square brackets and here we have
to write the elements so i'm gonna
include in these countries list just
strings and they're going to be
names of countries so the first one i'm
going to write united states so this is
the first
element in my list
and to
write the second we have to use the
comma so here comma and now the second
so let's write india
uh two more so
now china and finally brazil
so these are the four countries as you
can see here uh this is a list
so we have the square brackets that
represent the list and we have four
strings and this is how to define or how
you create a list so now i'm going to
run this one
and to see the content i'm going to
paste the name of this list and now i
run here i include only strings but keep
in mind that lists can have elements of
different types so for example one
string and the other an integer and then
a float and so on
and also lists can have duplicated
elements so for example i can have here
united states
written twice
so here for example i can write united
states
twice and
that's okay because lists can have
duplicated elements but i don't want it
that way so i'm gonna delete it and
leave it as it is okay now if we want to
get an element inside this list we have
to use something called indexing
by indexing we can obtain an element by
its position
so each item in a list has an index
which is the position in the list
python uses zero base indexing that is
the first element so united states has
an index 0 the second so india has an
index 1 and so on
to access an element by its index we
need to use the square brackets again so
let's see some examples
let's start by getting the first element
so united states so what we have to do
is to write the name of the list in this
case countries and then open square
brackets in inside square brackets we
have to write the position of this
element so it starts with zero so we
write zero to get the first element and
then we run this code and as you can see
we got the first element
so if we write here countries square
brackets 1 we get india and if we write
countries square brackets 2
we get china and if we do this with the
number three we get brazil
so to verify this i'm gonna print each
of them
so
let's see what happens so here print
and finally print this one and now i'm
gonna run
and we should get
uh each element of the list from united
states to brazil so let's try out
so here we have each of them united
states
the first one then india then china and
then brazil so it's correct so this is
the most common way to use indexing but
there is also negative index
this help us get elements starting on
the last position of the list
so instead of using indexes from 0 and
above we use indexes from -1 and below
so let's get the last element of the
list but now using a negative index so
we want to get the last element which is
brazil
and
we did it before with countries square
brackets three but now we're gonna do it
with negative indexing so here i'm gonna
write countries
i copy and paste it here
and now i open square brackets
and instead of writing three
we're gonna write minus one
and this minus one represents
the first element
starting from the last position so
brazil will be
minus one china
is minus two india minus three united
states minus four
and that's how it works so i'm gonna run
this one countries square brackets minus
one and we should get brazil and we got
it so let's do this one more time and in
this case i wanna get united states
which is minus one two three and four so
it's countries minus four so we run this
and we got united states but now using a
negative index okay now let's see
something called a slicing slicing means
accessing parts of lists as lies is a
subset of list elements
a slice notation takes the form of
list
so the list name and then square
brackets and the start
then
this colon and stop this start
represents the index of the first
element and stop represents the element
to stop at without including it in that
slice so let's see some examples so i'm
gonna use this countries list again
i just i'm gonna copy this one and
i'm gonna paste it here so this is the
name of my list
and now i open square brackets
and we're gonna get uh let's say we're
gonna start at position number zero
and then column and let's get
from zero to the position number two so
we have to write three because it stops
at three without including this element
in the position number 3. so let's run
this one and as you can see here we have
index 0
index 1 and index 2. so it didn't
include
index number three now let's say we want
just the first element so we write from
zero to one so it's only zero and one no
because it doesn't include one and it
stops at one so
here i run and we got only united states
so now let's try something different
let's say we want to get
uh elements from index one to the last
one
so
let's say
let me see here we want to get from
india to brazil so it's
one two and three
so we have to write four because it
stops at four and we got three
so
let's write here
one two four
and we should get yeah india china and
brazil
so
this is one way to do it but another way
to do it is just
delete this and leave it as it is and
then run the code
and as we can see we got the same result
so every time you want to get from one
position to the last one you can omit
the stop element and just leave it
without that element so
just as we did here and the same goes
for the start so let's say we want to
get from the first position so index 0
to 2. so we don't include the start
element and we write only colon and 2.
so we run this and we get united states
and then we get india because this is
the first and this is the second so
every time we want to get from the first
element or until the last element we can
omit that start and stop elements as we
did in these two examples okay now let's
see how we can add elements to a list
there are different methods that help us
add a new element to a list so let's
have a look
the first one is called append
and we're gonna use the counters list as
an example so i'm gonna write countries
just
so you can remember
and here it's countries and as you can
see it has four elements
and let's say we want to add a new
country to this country's list so what
we can do is
just
right here or paste here countries and
now add append
or that
append
and here
as you can see is this is a method
so inside parentheses we can write the
new country we want to add to this list
so let's say we want to add the country
canada
so we write canada
and now we run this code
as you can see nothing is printed but if
we print the counters list again
we see here a new element so as you can
see here the append method adds
a new element at the end of the list so
it is by default at the end
but what happens if you want to add an
element in a different position
so here you can use another method which
is called the insert method so let me
show you here
i'm gonna copy countries and now i'm
gonna use the insert method
so i write that insert then parenthesis
and this one
accepts two arguments the first one is
the index so the position of the element
you want to insert
so let's say we want this at the first
position
and the second argument that it takes
is the
new element you want to add so in this
case
let's say we want to add the elements
pane so this is uh
another country and it's gonna be
in the first position so index zero
so let's try i run this one and again
nothing happens apparently nothing
happens
and here if i
run this
countries list again
we can see that there is a new element
and this element is spain and it's
located in the first position
unlike canada that was
placed in the last position this is one
of the difference between the
append method and the insert method so
with insert we can specify the position
we want to insert this new element but
with append the element is added at the
last position another thing you can do
is to
join two lists using the plus operator
we use the
task operator to concatenate strings
before but you can also join two lists
so let me show you here
i'm gonna create a new list just to show
you how it works so my new list is gonna
be called uh countries underscore two so
i'm gonna include different countries so
in this case it's gonna be
the uk
then germany and
let's write austria
so
we have three countries in this new list
and now
i'm gonna run this one
and
if we want to concatenate these uh first
list countries
with this second list
countries two
we can use the plus operator so here
i write plus
and then i run this one and as you can
see i got the five elements from the
first list
and three elements from the second list
and another cool thing you can do in
python is putting these two lists inside
another list which is called nested list
so let's try out so here i'm gonna
create a new list and it's gonna be
called nested underscore list
and here i'm gonna open square brackets
to create a new list and as elements i'm
gonna write countries which is my
my first list
and then comma
and then countries underscore two
and this is my second list so as you can
see here these
elements inside this list the first is a
list and the second is list so we have a
list inside another list which is called
a nested list so i run this one
and then
i paste nested
underscore list and we run and we get
here
the first list as first element and the
second list as second element you won't
see this nested list so often but you
will encounter this a couple of times so
it's good for you to know so now we're
gonna see the opposite of adding an
element to a list which is removing an
element so here i just pasted the
countries list we had before
and what we're going to do is to remove
some of the elements of this list
so there are different methods that help
us remove an element from a list
one of them is the remove method so to
remove an element using this we have to
first write the name of the list
and then
use that that sign
and then write remove
and
write parentheses in inside here we have
to write the element
we want to get rid of so first it's
united states
so i write united states
and
let's run this one and as you can see
apparently nothing happens but if we
paste countries here we have
uh all the elements but united states is
not there so as you can see the first
matching value was removed
but you can also remove an element by
its index
so
this is
accomplished with the pop method so i'm
going to copy all of this
and now i'm going to paste it here so
instead of writing that remove i'm going
to write that pop and here
i'm not gonna
use the name of the element but it's
index
so i write the index in this case let's
remove the last one
so it's gonna be index minus one and
what pop is gonna do is to remove the
element with index minus one and then
returns this element so this element is
canada i didn't run this code here so
you can ignore it so i'm going to
comment this one and our reference is
going to be this this list and
to verify we just write countries and
then run and here as you can see there
isn't canada anymore and that's how you
remove an element using the pop method
but there's still another way to remove
an item using an specific index and it's
the dell so i'm gonna show you here
dell
it's uh
the function dell function
and here we have to write the
countries
list and then again open square brackets
and here write that index so
i write here the index and unlike the
pop method we're not going to get the
name of the element we're getting rid of
but just deleting the element so i run
this one
and here we didn't get anything
and i'm gonna print this
so countries and that
element at index 0 was removed so spain
because that's the first element so
we
delete it or we remove the first element
so we only got india china and brazil
and there you have it three different
ways to remove an element from a list
okay now let's see how to sort a list we
can easily sort a list using the sort
method let's create a new list called
numbers and then sort it from the
smallest to the largest number so here
first i write numbers and then open
square brackets so
i'm going to write some random numbers
so first
4 then 3
then 10
then 7 1 and then 2.
so this is my list
so i run this code and now to sort it
from the smallest to the largest number
we write numbers then sort
then open parenthesis
and by default this is going to be
sorted from the smallest to the largest
number so i run numbers again and here
it starts with 1 and it ends with 10
and as you can see it's from the
smallest to the largest number
so that's the default behavior of the
sort method but we can control how this
works
so we can add that reverse argument to
the store method to control the order so
if we want it to be descendant we set
reverse to true so here again i'm gonna
create again the numbers list
and then write numbers
that sort
and inside parenthesis
i write the reverse argument and i'm
gonna set it to true here
and then i'm gonna print numbers so here
i got an error because here it i wrote
number and it's numbers so here i'm
gonna add the s and here s2 so run again
and here we have uh from the
and here we see that the list
is
sorted from the largest number to the
smallest number so as you can see the
default behavior of this sort method is
reverse equal to false so you can
control it here by writing reverse equal
to true as we did here okay now let's
see how we can update values in a list
to update a value on a list we use
indexing to locate that element we want
to update and then we set it to a new
value using that equal sign so let's say
we want to
update the first element of this numbers
list so now it's 4 but we want it to be
let's say 1 000 so we write here numbers
and we use indexing so we write numbers
the first element has index zero so we
write numbers square brackets then zero
then we set it equal to the new value we
want to
include so in this case i'm gonna write
one
1000
and now i'm going to print the
numbers list to see the results so
run this one and as you can see here the
numbers list we got is from the last
change we made so the one that starts
with 10 so it's not this one but this
one because it's the last one we ran so
instead of 10
we replace this one with 1000 because
this is the first element with index
zero so we did
numbers square brackets zero and we
update that first element with one
thousand okay finally we can make copies
of the lists we created so there are
different options to create a copy of a
list one of them is that slicing
technique so as you might remember to do
slicing we have
first to write the name of the list
which this case is countries
and then we open square brackets
then we're supposed to write the start
and stop so in this case we're not going
to write start and stop but only colon
so if we don't write start and we don't
write stop it means we want the whole
list so let's try this out i'm going to
run this one and as you can see here
we got the whole list
so the contours list doesn't have the
original values because of the changes
we made when we added and remove
elements so i'm gonna paste the original
counters list with the four original
values that are united states india
china and brazil and here let's see the
changes and now we test it out and as
you can see we got the whole list so
from the first element united states to
the last element brazil because we're
slicing the whole list so if we write
here
new underscore list
and we set this equal to
countries with this slicing
what it's going to happen is this new
list is going to have the same values as
the counter list so i write here new
list and as you can see here it has the
same values so we created a copy of the
counters list so this is one way how you
can
create a copy and the second way is
more straightforward or is it more
explicit so
it's using that copy method
so we write again countries the name of
the list and then we use the copy method
so we write copy and then parentheses so
with this we create a copy of this list
so let's run this code and as you can
see here
it returns the list but if we assign
this to a new list we're gonna create a
copy so here i'm gonna write
new underscore list underscore two so
here
we assign this copy to this new list so
i'm gonna copy this new list and paste
it here
and as you can see here
we have the values of this list which
are the same as the original countries
list that is here and that's it that's
how you make a copy of a list
so now let's see how dictionaries work
in python in python a dictionary is an
ordered collection of items used to
store data values and a dictionary
contains a key and a value so this is
what you will often see in a dictionary
so here for example the name of my
dictionary is my underscore dict and to
create this dictionary we have to use
these curly braces
so we open curly braces and inside we
write our first item and the first item
consists of a key here on the left and
then a
value here
and it's
separated with the colon so here we have
the key then column and then the value
and then we have here the second item so
the second key and the second value so
now let's create a dictionary that has
some basic information about me so i'm
gonna name this dictionary my underscore
data
and now to create this dictionary i'm
going to open crawley braces
and the first key is going to be name so
i write name
and it has
a value that is my name so i'm gonna
write frank so i open single quotes and
then write frank
and then i'm gonna add a new item so i
write comma and then the second key is
gonna be
h
and the second value is gonna be my h so
in this case i'm gonna write my h which
is
26. so as you can see here the first
is a string the first value is a string
and the second is uh
integer so we can mix different data
types so now i press ctrl enter to run
this
code and we created this dictionary so
now
i write my underscore data and here you
have the dictionary we created
so here we can get the keys of this
dictionary we only have to write my
underscore data that keys so this is the
keys method so we run this
and we
get this dick underscore keys and the
values are name and h which are the keys
of this dictionary we created so name
the first key and h the second key
now we can get also the values so my
name and my h
so we just have to use that values
method so
i'm gonna paste this one here and
instead of
writing that keys i'm gonna write that
values and now run this and we get my
name and then my h
so next i'm gonna get the items so as i
said before an item is this so this is
the first item and this is the second
item so we can say that the item
is a pair of key and volume so we can
get this by using the items method so
instead of writing that values i'm going
to write here that items
and then run this one
so here we got the first item
so the first pair key and value which is
my name and
well that key
name and then my name frank and then the
second item so the key name h and the h
which is 26. now we can add a new pair
of key value in this dictionary we
created so let's say we want to add my
height so i
write my data and let's say we want to
add the key
name height so
i write height
so we use square brackets here
and then we set this to the value so
let's say uh it's
1.7 so i write my data and then square
brackets then height inside it and then
equal to
1.7
so if i run this
and then i run the dictionary we can see
that there is a new item
and it's the height so height
column and then 1.7
this is how you add a new item to the
dictionary and now we can update this
height so let's say
i'm not 1.7 but i'm 1.8 meters so what
we can do is to use the update method to
update this
value so
i write
my underscore data
and here
i can use the update method so i write
update and then inside parentheses we
have to open curly braces to update
these new items so i'm gonna write the
key which is height
and then i'm gonna set the new height
which is 1.8
so let's try this out
i run this and then let's see the values
so let's see if it was updated so i run
this and we got the height 1.8 so it's
perfect
so now let's see how we can make a copy
of a dictionary the same way we did
before for the lists so to make a copy
we just have to write the name of the
dictionary in this case it's my
underscore data
and then just as we did for the list we
can use the copy method so we
write that copy with parentheses and
then we create a new copy
so here you can see the copy and now i
can assign this to a new dictionary so
i'm going to write new underscore dict
and now i'm going to copy this one i'm
going to run and then
i write new underscore dict and run this
and as you can see it has the value of
the my underscore data dictionary
and something i didn't tell you when i
make a copy of the list
is that if you change the
data inside that
my underscore data dictionary so the old
dictionary
that effect is not going to be seen in
the new dictionary so for example if we
write
1.9
and here
i update this in the old dictionary so
here you can see height 1.9
and if we run this new underscore dict
we can see that after running this
height remains with the same value 1.8
and it doesn't change to 1.9 this
doesn't happen if you
make one of these copies most people do
so let me
show you what i'm talking about so most
people just make a copy doing
new dick underscore 2 equal to my data
so this is the old dictionary and this
is my new dictionary so what happens if
i run this
and then
i
i'm going to show you the values of this
new dictionary so this is 1.9 and if i
update this to
let's say
1.95 so update here
update here
here is 1.95
and if i run this new underscore dict
underscore 2
we can see that the value was updated
too
and this shouldn't happen so if you want
to create a new dictionary that works
independently from the old dictionary
you should use that copy method and this
is the same if you're making a copy of a
list finally let's see how to remove
elements from a dictionary
so
just like we did with the lists we can
remove an item in a dictionary so there
are different options first we have the
pop method so write
my underscore data i'm using the old
dictionary we've been using so far
so my underscore data
and i'm gonna write that pop so this is
the pop method so here i can write that
key so in this case i'm gonna write the
key
let me see here uh my underscore data
the key
name so i write
pop then parenthesis then name so
as you might remember the pop method
returns this
value of that key
before we did with that list and it
returned the list element in this case
it returns the value of that key so this
is the key name and it returns the value
so if we print this my underscore data
dictionary we see that
this pair
key
value isn't here so
we successfully remove this item another
way to remove an element or an item from
a dictionary is using that delt
function so we write del and then we
write the
name of the dictionary so my underscore
data and then we have to specify again
the name of the key so we open square
brackets and
uh open
quotes and here let's say we want to
delete the or remove the
h key with its value so we write h
and
we run this and then if we print this
dictionary again we get
the dictionary and we see that the h key
was removed and also its value and
finally you can remove all the items in
a dictionary with the clear method so we
write my underscore data and use that
clear with parentheses and now if we
print this
dictionary
you can see that this is an empty
dictionary because we remove all the
elements from this dictionary
now let's see one of the most common
statements used in python
this is the if statement
the if statement is a conditional
statement used to decide whether a
certain statement or block of statements
will be executed or not here you can see
the syntax of this if statement and as
you can see it starts with the if
keyword
followed by the condition so if the
condition is true this code here is
going to be executed and if the
condition is not true so it's false the
code here in the alif it's going to be
tested so here in this alif block this
new condition will be tested and if this
is true this code below will be executed
but if it's not true
then the else block will be tested and
here this is the last block and
automatically this code will be executed
so here one little detail that most
beginners forget to write is the column
so
it's sometimes easy to forget it's there
but you have to include it
and one other things
some people miss is this indentation so
here there is an indentation you have to
include
after the column so
every time you write here column
you press enter and you automatically in
most test editors you're gonna get this
indentation but if for some reason you
don't get that indentation
and you get something like this you can
indent this
uh line by using the tab key and your
keyboard so just press tab
and it's gonna indent this line so make
sure you write the column and you
include an indentation for each code
that will be executed so here
here and here so now let's have a look
at some examples to see much better how
the if statement works so first i'm
going to create a new variable and as
you might remember to create a variable
you have to write a name of this
variable in this case i'm going to name
it h
and then you have to set it a value so
in this case this is going to be a
number so i'm going to set this h to the
number 18
and now i'm gonna write this if
condition
or if statement so i write if
h is
greater than
or equal to 18
then column and then
this
code is going to be executed so if this
is true i'm going to write
print
and then a message so if this person or
if the h is equal or greater than 18 i'm
gonna write the message
your
and adult and as you can see here i'm
using single quotes and i wrote that
apostrophe so
i'm gonna use double quotes
and everything is fine now so here print
uh then the message you're an adult
so if this isn't true i write
else
and then
column and print uh here a new message
which is
you are a kid
so let's see this again
so if the h
is
equal or greater than 18 then we print
you're an adult but if it's
uh
less than 18 we print you're a kid so
here
we run this code and we should get this
because 18 is equal to 18 so let's
run and as you can see we got the
message
you are an adult so now we can play with
this we can change the age value
so here i'm going to set it to
15. so i run and as you can see here
15 is less than 18 so this is false and
this code is executed so this block here
it's going to be executed so we got you
are a kid
so we can try this one more time so in
this case i'm going to write another h
so 30 and again 30 is greater than 18 so
this is executed so you're an adult so
now let's add a new block and i'm gonna
use the alif
so i write alif
and then h
and then
greater than let's say
13
and then column
press enter and we got this indentation
and then we print another message so if
the h is
equal to or greater than
13
we write the message you are a teenager
so teenager
so
if it's between 13 and
a 17 or well less than 18 it's gonna be
you're a teenager but if it's less than
13
it's going to be jar a kid so let's try
this out
so i write first 10
and then
we get your kid because
it's less than 13. then we'll
change this to
14
and then we get your teenager because 14
is greater than 13
and finally we write 20
and we get
you're an adult because 20 is greater
than 18.
and that's it that's how the if
statement works
now it's time to see one of the most
common loops in python this is the for
loop python for loops are used to loop
through an iterable object and performs
the same action for each entry
one example of an iterable object is a
list so we can loop through each element
of a list and perform the same action on
each element of that list here you can
see the syntax of the for loop and as
you can see
here is the four keyword and then we
have to use a variable then we have to
write that in keyword and then that
iterable in this case as i told you
before the most common is the list so
you have four variable in list
i'm gonna write here list so you can see
much better and then we have to write
that column
and then after a column it goes an
indentation so here we have the
indentation and the code that will be
executed for each iteration here that we
make with the for loop so to see this
much better i'm going to use the
countries list we created before so this
is the countries list and i'm going to
look through this list so i write 4
and then we have to set a variable that
is going to be just just temporarily
so this variable is going to be called
country
so this variable doesn't exist we just
created temporarily so for country in
and then we have to write the name of
that iterable which is in this case a
list so
countries
so for country in countries and then
column and then enter and we get this
indentation
then we say
print
country
so for this variable in this
iterable which is a list
print each element this is what we're
saying in this
for loop so we
run this and as you can see
each element of the list country is
printed so we're looping through the
countries list and printing each element
so the first is united states then india
then china and brazil and this is how
the for loop works now let me show you a
new function that you can implement
along with a for loop and it's called
enumerate so i'm going to write here
enumerate
and here i'm going to put these
countries list inside this new function
so what this enumerate function does is
to enumerate each element of the
countries list as we loop through the
list so
i'm going to add here
a new
variable and it's going to be i then
comma and then country so this enumerate
will return two elements the first one
is gonna be the number of the loop
and the second one is gonna be the
element itself so here i have to print
apart from the country the
i
variable that i just created here or
it's just temporarily here
so right print
i
and then print country
so
here we're going to print here the
number of the iteration and the element
so i run
ctrl enter and here we got it so first
is united states in the iteration
the first iteration with each which is
zero
then we got india in the second
iteration which has uh one
and so on so as you can see here uh the
i
starts with the
zero so this is how enumerate works it
starts with the number zero and it
returns the number of the loop and that
element and finally let's loop through
elements in a dictionary
so
let's use the dictionary we created
before that was my underscore data
well this is empty so i'm gonna use the
original dictionary so here i have the
original dictionary and it's here so i'm
just going to print it so this is the
dictionary and now we're going to loop
through this dictionary so let me show
you here
first we have to write 4
and then
we write key
and value because one item as you might
remember is made of a key
and the value so key and value so we say
for key coma value in and then the name
of the dictionary
so write
my underscore data and now to get the
items of this dictionary we have to use
the items method so we write dot
items
and then parentheses
then we
write column and we press enter
so here we can print the key
and we can also print the value
so key and value and then we run this
code and as you can see here
we get the key the first key
and we get the value we get name and we
get frank and then the second key h and
h 26 so this is how you loop through
elements or items inside a dictionary
okay now let's see how functions work in
python a function is a block of code
which only runs when it is called
you can pass data known as parameters
into a function so here it's the syntax
of a function and as you can see here we
have first to
set the keyword def to create this
function and then we have to write the
name of this function and inside
parentheses we define the parameters of
the function that we're creating
then we write column and below you have
to write the code and every function
should return something so we have to
use that return keyword and then return
something like a variable for example so
now let's create a basic function
so
first we write def and then we write the
name of the function so this function is
going to do something really simple it's
going to sum the values we pass into it
so it's going to be named
sum underscore values and as parameters
we said a comma b
then column and press enter
then what this function is going to do
is to add
the a plus v values and we're going to
set this equal to x so we write x equal
to a plus b and as i told you before you
should return something after we finish
that function so we write return and
here we're going to return the x
variable so you write
x
and that's it that's how you create a
function i ran this
code and as you can see
apparently nothing happens but this
function was created so to
use this function we have to call it so
to call this function we have to write
the name of the function
and then we pass
some parameters in in this case it's
called arguments when you call the
function so
i'm going to write
argument one and argument three so once
you call this function it's gonna go to
the function here and it's gonna set
this one equal to a and this three equal
to b
so you have 1 plus
3 and this is 4 so x is going to be
equal to 4 and then this function is
going to return the value of x which is
4. so this is supposed to return the
value of four so we run this
and we got a value of four so this
function is working properly okay now
let's see some built-in functions that
python has python has lots of built-in
functions that can help us perform a
specific task let's have a look at some
of them
so let's start with the length function
we only have to write the word land
and then we open parenthesis and as you
can see here jupiter notebook gives the
green color to functions
and now let's calculate the length of
the countries list so i have here the
countries list and now i'm going to copy
this one
paste it inside parenthesis
and what the length function is going to
do is to calculate the length of any
iterable object in this case the
countries list is an iterable object and
now i'm going to run to calculate the
length of this object so i run this one
and as you can see here the length is
four and this is how the length function
works now let's see a different function
in this case
i'm going to create a new list that
contains only numbers so i'm going to
write random numbers here
10 63
81 then
1 then 99 so this is my new list and i
created this list with only numbers to
try the max and min function
so the max function is this one we write
max and then parenthesis and this one
returns the item with the highest value
in an iterable so my iterable is this
list and we're going to get the highest
value of the elements inside this list
so we run this one
and as you can see here the maximum
value is 99
and we can do also the mean function and
it's gonna have the opposite effect in
this case we're going to get the minimum
value of this list so we run
and we get
1. okay another common function used in
python is the type function and this
function give us the type of the object
we only have to write type
and what this function does is to return
the type of an object so in this case
let's copy and paste the countries
object and if we run this we can see
that this object is a list
and that's correct because here we
created a list with square brackets
so that's what the type function does
and finally the last function we're
going to see is the range function
this one
returns a sequence of numbers that start
with
a number and ends with another number so
let's see how it works here so this one
has three arguments first the start
number
this one i'm gonna write one
then the number where the sequence stops
in this case i'm going to write let's
say 10
and then the last argument is the
increment so how the this sequence is
going to grow by how
much so in this case i'm going to say
that this sequence is going to grow by
two so i write two
now i run and as you can see nothing
happens we only get the same text here
but if we make a loop here so i write
four i in range
now print
this i
so this is a for loop we saw this before
and here we run and as you can see here
we're iterating over this range and
we're getting the elements inside this
range so the first element is one
the second is incremented by two so one
plus two is three
then three plus two five then seven and
then nine
and then we should get eleven but the
last element here
it's ten so this sequence stops at ten
so we only get until number nine
and that's how the range
function works in python and that's it
now you know the most common built-in
functions in python
okay in this video we're going to see
what are modules in python in python
modules are files that contain python
code a module can have classes
functions and variables and even
runnable code and to get access to a
module we have to use the import keyword
this one and to see a module in action
we're gonna see the os module and this
one comes with python so you don't need
to install it so to get access to this
os module we have to write import os
and that's it we only write this and now
let's see some functionalities of this
module so
the first one that we're going to see is
the
get current directory method so to get
access to that method we write os then
get c
w d and then
parentheses so this cwd stands for
current working directory so we're gonna
get the directory where our jupyter
notebook file is located so this file
i'm working with right now
so
let's run and let's see what happens so
as you can see here i have the path
where the jupiter notebook is located so
this is the
complete path and you can see it by
using the get cwd
method
so
now let's see another method and in this
case we're gonna list all the elements
in the folder where this
jupyter notebook file is located so here
to do that we're going to use the method
list dur
so this means list directory and i'm
going to run it and as you can see here
i have this
jupyter notebook file that is named
untitled as you can see here the name of
my file is untitled
and these other elements you can ignore
it they are not files they are just some
hidden elements in my folder but they
don't matter so right now the only file
i have in this folder is this untitled
file
so
this is what the lister does
so it lists all the elements in the
folder where this jupyter notebook file
is located and now let's see the last
method which help us create a new folder
so this method is called make doors and
we have to write os dot
make
dears
and then parentheses and inside
parenthesis we have to write the name of
the folder we want to create so in this
case i'm going to name it
new folder
simple as that
and now if we run we're going to see
that nothing happens but now if we use
this list dealer method to list all the
elements in my folder
we can see that
there is a new folder so here if we
compare this
result we got before with this new
result we can see that there is one new
element and this element is the new
folder element which is the folder we
created using the make durs method and
that's it those are some basic things
you can do with the os module in the
following videos we're gonna install
different libraries packages and modules
so we can do even more things in python
in this first introduction to pandas
we're going to learn what this pen does
we're going to compare pandas with excel
and then we're going to learn
what are pandas data frames
so first
pandas is probably the best tool to do
real world data analysis in python
it allows us to clean
data wrangle data make visualizations
and more
you can think of pandas as a
supercharged microsoft excel
because most of the tasks you can do in
excel you can also do it in pandas and
vice versa
that said there are many areas where
pandas outperforms excel so before you
learn pandas let me show you why you
should learn pandas especially if you
already know excel
so there are some benefits that pandas
has over excel or
python has over excel
so before dedicating time to learning
pandas and also python
let's see what are these benefits so
first limitation by size excel can
handle
around 1 million rows while python can
handle millions and millions of rows
another benefit that python and pandas
have over excel is a complex data
transformation
so in excel memory intensive
computations can crash a workbook
while in python
when you work with pandas you can handle
complex computations without any major
problem also python is good for
automation
while excel was not designed to automate
tasks you can create a macro or use vva
to simplify some tasks but that's the
limit however python can go beyond that
with its hundred of free libraries
available and finally python has
cross-platform capabilities
this means that python code remains the
same regardless of the operating system
or language set on your computer
okay before start writing code let me
explain to you the core concepts of
pandas
so we're going to start seeing the
concepts of arrays
so arrays in python are a data structure
like lists
so you can find like one dimensional
array or two dimensional rate also known
as 2d array
and the two main data structures in
pandas
are series and data frames
so the first is a one dimensional array
while the second a data frame is a two
dimensional array in pendants we mainly
work with data frames
but if you didn't understand so much the
definition of a data frame with arrays
let me show you another definition this
one
using excel
so appends data frame is the equivalent
of an excel spreadsheet
pandas data frames just like excel
spreadsheet
have two dimensions or access
so
there are two axes and one
is the row
and the other is the column
so the column is also known as series so
what we've seen before this one
dimensional array series is a column
this is another name to call the columns
in
independence data frame
on top of the data frame you will see
the name of the columns and on the left
side there is the index
by default index impedance start with
zero
the intersection of a row with a column
is called a data value or simply data
we can store different types of data
such as integers strings boolean
and so on
right now you see on the screen a data
frame that shows
the u.s states ranked by population i'm
going to show you the code to create a
data frame like this later
but now let's analyze this data frame so
the column names
are also known as features so our
features here are states population
and postal
while each row value is known as
observation
we can say that there are three features
and four observations because there are
three columns and four rows keep in mind
that a single column should have the
same type of data
in our example the states and postal
columns only contains strings while the
population column only contains integers
we might get errors when trying to
insert different data types into a
column so avoid mixing different type of
data so now let's see that terminology
translation between excel and pandas so
as i mentioned before
in excel we work with worksheets and in
pandas we work with data frames
so the columns in excel are also known
as series in pandas but we also mention
or we also say often the word columns
and
in pandas we work with index
so the index are those numbers that are
on the left and in pandas we also say
rows we have many rows well observations
too but rows
are fine
and finally in pandas we
work often with this n a n that stands
for not a number and this is the
equivalent of an empty cell that you
might find in excel so that's it for now
in the next video we're going to learn
how to create a pandas data frame from
scratch
welcome back in this video we're going
to learn different ways to create
appendix data frame
so as you might remember a data frame
looks like this it has columns and rows
and the columns are series
so
series
are a 1d array and arrays is how we
create a data frame so this is the first
way to create a data frame with arrays
so these are arrays we have 1d arrays 2d
arrays
and 1d arrays are basically columns
while 2d arrays are data frames
so
usually to use arrays we use a library
named numpy
and numpy is
what is under the hood of pandas so to
use numpy we have first to import numpy
we're gonna do that a bit later when we
write code but just to give you an idea
what a numpy array looks like here i
wrote a basic array
we have to use np that array to create
this
data frame that you see
on the right and well this is one way to
do it you can also use lists as i'm
showing you right now
and
as you can see here in the second option
when you create a data frame with lists
you don't need to use numpy arrays
because you're using some kind of list
arrays so we're going to write the code
to create a data frame with arrays but
let's see the second option to create a
data frame
so the second option is dictionaries you
can create a data frame with
dictionaries
and
as you might remember a dictionary has a
key
and a value
so we can use the
key as column name and the value as the
data
so the value can be a list
so this
data will be
many elements inside a list
so a pair
of key and value is known as item in a
dictionary and in this case is going to
be a series because it's one column what
we have here
so this is the second way to create a
data frame with dictionaries and we're
gonna see that with code a little bit
later but now let's see the third way
which is with csv files so csv files are
files that can be opened in spreadsheets
like excel
and this is the easiest way to create a
data frame because we only need to read
the csv file and then the data frame is
created and that's it so now let's go to
jupyter notebook to create a data frame
writing some code okay now we are on
jupyter notebook and here we're gonna
write the code to create a data frame
and we're gonna use the three ways i
showed you before so the first thing
we're going to do
is to import the libraries we're going
to use to create a data frame
so that's the first line of code and i
already
wrote that so
it's here so first we import pandas and
then we import numpy
so import pandas is pd pd is used a
convention to name pandas
and np is
a way to name numpy so to run this code
just press ctrl enter and now
just wait and we imported pandas and
numpy so let's see the first way to
create a data frame so the first is
with arrays and
to create an array we have to use a
numpy this is the first option so we
write np
which is the short name for numpy
and then we use the array method so we
write array
open parenthesis and inside we write the
array we want to create
so i'm going to create uh i'm going to
write random numbers just for the sake
of this example so
i open double square brackets and then
let's write let's say one and four
and then
let's say two and five and the last one
it's gonna be three and six
so each pair of let's call it list
actually they are lists
uh each list represent a row so this is
the first row or this is going to be the
first row
this is going to be the second row in
our data frame and this is going to be
the third row
so here we can name this rate and i'm
going to name it as data
so that is equal to this number array so
i'm going to execute this
code
and now we have this data
so we created the array using numpy now
let's create a data frame with pandas so
to create a data frame with pandas we
have to write pandas in this case i can
write pd because i name it like this
here in my first line of code
so i write pd
and then to create a data frame we use
the
the data frame method so we write dot
data frame and then
we open parenthesis and here we have to
fill some
arguments
so the first one and that's
what something that you always have to
include in this data frame method is the
data because you cannot create a data
frame without
data so first we include the data so
first
copy here our array and then you paste
it here
that's the first argument
so you can create this data frame as it
is i'm going to show you here just
control
and enter so as you can see here here is
my data frame but as you can see it's
full of numbers and uh
column names also have numbers and the
row names also have numbers so to make
it more
understandable we can
rename this um
these column names and row names
or index actually the name of the row
names are index
so first we can name this index as rows
for example we you only need to add the
index argument
as i'm writing right now
and then you have to specify the names
you want to set
so you have to open a
list
so this
first or this second argument has a form
of list
so the first element is gonna be the
first index so here
zero so in case you don't want it to be
zero you can set here another name so in
my case i'm gonna set it as row one
then comma to set the second index as
row two
and the third as row
three
so now we can add uh also or we can
modify also the column names we have to
use the column argument
and here we write it columns
and then
we open square brackets because it's a
list here that we're gonna edit
and
in this case we have to modify only two
elements so the first gonna be
i wanna name it uh call
one
and the second cool two
so i'm gonna write this one
and actually i'm gonna name this data
frame
so i'm gonna set it to a variable and
this is gonna be equal to df
df it's the
common way to name a data frame so df
stands for data frame so i'm gonna run
this code now
and
as you can see here it ran
and now to show the data frame i can
write here df so df
and now we have here
the data frame
and as you can see here the first row
one four it's my first uh
my first list
and the second is the second uh row
and the first column well that's a
series as we discussed before
so we have also the column names that we
modified and the row names so now let's
quickly see how to create a data frame
with arrays but in this case without
numpy so i'm gonna copy this
line of code and i'm gonna paste it here
option two
so here i'm gonna paste this because
this is the base of uh this
arrays with this shape
and i'm gonna just delete this so i
don't want numpy array
anymore just this
double square brackets
so i run this
now
to create the data frame is
the same way we did before so just
copy this
and paste it here
so run this and now i can run the i can
write the f and now execute this code so
as you can see we have the same result
i'm just showing you the second way so
you don't have to worry about learning
right now numpy
okay now let's create a data frame from
a dictionary and we're gonna use lists
in this example and we're gonna create a
data frame using more meaningful data
so in this case to create a dictionary
i'm gonna use two lists the first is
gonna be a list name states in the
second it's gonna be the population and
it will contain the population of each
state so the first list is states and
i'm gonna write it here and i open
square brackets because this is a list
and now i write some
states in
in the us so the first is california
the second is going to be texas oh let
me write it here the third is gonna be
florida and the last one
new york so
i quickly write it here and now i'm
gonna create the population list so in
this case i'm going to pay
so in this case i'm going to paste this
data so i pasted the population on each
state and now i'm going to create a
dictionary from these two lists so i'm
going to
write the name of the dictionary so
uh the names gonna be dict
underscore states
then this is a dictionary so i should
use
square brackets sorry curly braces and
now i'm gonna set the name of the key so
the first key
is states
then colon
and now the element or the value so
this is
states
the first value and the second key and
value
is population
i'm just gonna set it to uh with capital
letter
and the second is the
list population that we have here so
with this we create our dictionary
so i'm gonna run these two
and now we have lists and a dictionary
so now we can easily create a data frame
using the
data frame method that we used before
for the first option when we created a
data frame with an array so to do it
just write pd
then that data frame
and now we have to write inside
parentheses the name of the dictionary
so
i'm going to copy dict underscore states
and
i'm going to set this to a new
variable so i'm going to name this df
underscore population
so
data frame about population so now i run
this
and here i got an error because i didn't
write data frame correctly
here is in capital letter so i run again
and now everything is okay
so now to show the data frame i just
paste this one here
and now i run
so here we have this data frame
and as you can see here my first key
states is the name of my first column
and the data inside the states
list is here so here is my first column
or my first
series and the same goes for population
with its data
so here we created a data frame using a
dictionary okay finally let's create a
data frame from a csv file
to create a data frame from a csv file
we have to use the read underscore csv
method so first we write as usual pd
that stands for pandas and then we use
the method so we write read underscore
csv
open parenthesis
and then we have to write the name of
this csv file here i'm going to paste
the name so its name
students performance that's csv and to
download this data you can check the
notes of this video and actually we can
have a look at this data before
importing into pandas so it's here i
have it in google sheets and as you can
see here we have this course of some
exams math reading and writing
and we have some other data so we can
import all of this data all of the
1000 rows in pandas so
all of this is going to be here so
here we only have to
define the
name of this data frame so here i'm
going to name it df underscore exams so
now i run and to show
now the first five rows of this data
frame we can use a method named head
that we're gonna
see later but just to give you an idea
of this we can write that head and we
get the first five rows so as you can
see here we have the first five rows of
this
um
excel or actually csv file
and as you can see here for example the
first row it says female group b
and math score 72 so let's check if that
data is the same here
so we have female group b and math score
72
so we have all this data here in this
data frame so if we want to see all of
them all of the rows here
we can
uh forget about the dot head and now we
have all the rows
well here uh we cannot see part of the
rows i'm going to show you
how to see that part
later
in this course but now as you can see if
we run this df under core exams we can
see like the summary of this
data set or well data frame in this case
by the way in pandas or when we work
actually in python we usually call this
type of csv files we call it data sets
and when we read a data set using well
pandas the result is a data frame what
we have here
so the csv file is a data set and this
uh when we read it with pandas is a data
frame and that's it these are the three
ways to create appendix data frame
okay now it's time to see
how to display a data frame in pandas so
here i have the csv file we used before
to create a data frame
and a little detail i forgot to mention
before
is that this csv file should be located
in the same directory where your jupyter
notebook script is located
so what i mean by the jupyter notebook
script is what
we're seeing right now i mean the
what we're working right now is a
jupiter notebook script this this file
that we're working right now so what you
have to do is to download this
csv file and place it in the same folder
where your python or your jupyter
notebook script is located in the same
folder and this is how you're going to
read this csv file using the read
underscore csv method so just make sure
both the csv file and the jupyter
notebook script is in the same place in
the same folder okay
now i'm gonna run these first two lines
of codes that we've seen before so the
first import pandas and the second reads
this csv file so i run this
and now we have this csv file stored
into this df underscore exams this is my
data frame
so now let's see how we can see this
data frame so the easiest way to see
this data frame is just copying this
name this variable and now paste it here
now i execute this and now we have the
data frame
actually this is a summary of the data
frame because
not all the rows are seen here so here
if we
scroll down a little bit we can see here
that
there are 1 thousand rows and 8 8
columns so here we can see
all these rows uh
and the columns but as you can see here
in the middle we cannot see the
the rows so it's until four and then it
continues with
995.
so usually when we work with pandas we
don't need to see
the data one by one so row by row that's
not how we do it with pandas but if for
some reason you need to see all the data
in pandas as you will do it here in
excel or in google sheets
i'm going to show you a way to do it a
bit later
but first i'm going to show you uh
different ways how we usually
display a data frame in pandas
so the first
way to do it is using the head method so
here to use the head method we only have
to write the name of the data frame in
this case df underscore exams and then
write head
then parenthesis
then we run this and this is how we get
the first five rows in a data frame so
as you can see here we have uh
from row zero to row four and this is
how we got these first five rows
so this is the head method in the same
way we can get the last five rows of
this data frame
by using the tails method
so here we only have to write again the
name of the data frame in this case well
the same df underscore exams
and then
write that tails then parenthesis
run this and actually i think it's tail
yeah it's tail in singular
and
now we get this uh we got the last five
rows so it's from 995 to 999
so these are the five rows the last five
rows
and now in case you want to get more
rows so not only the first five or the
last five rows you can add an argument
to the either the head or the tails
method
so i'm going to use here the head method
as an example
so here i copied this
and now i'm going to paste here so let's
say now we want to get the first 10 rows
so
we write here inside parentheses 10 and
now we run this and i scroll down here
and we can see that the first 10 rows
are here
and we can do the same with tail so here
i write tail
and as we can see the last 10 rows are
displayed here so you can specify the
number of rows that you want to display
and that's how you do it so now i'm
going to show you how to display all the
rows of this data frame as you will do
it in excel or in google sheets to do so
first we have to know how many columns
this data frame has so an easy way to
get the number of columns is using the
shape attribute
to get the shape attribute first we
write the name of the data frame so in
this case df underscore exams
and then to get to this attribute to get
access to this attribute we use the that
and then the name of the attribute in
this case shape
so now
we run this and we get
1008 the first is the number of rows and
the second is the number of columns so
we have 1000 rows so now to display all
the rows we have to use the set
underscore option method so we're right
pd
dot set underscore option
and inside parenthesis our first
argument is gonna be the following
display
dot max underscore rows
so here we have to specify one more
argument and this is going to be
the number of rows we wanted to
to have so here it's 1 000 because we
have 1 000 rows
and we run this and as you can see here
nothing happened because we only
modified the default behavior of pandas
so if we want to get the
the data frame
we just
press enter and execute this data frame
i'm going to scroll down in here as you
can see here
uh there are all the rows of this data
frame so i'm going to scroll all the way
down here
and as you can see it says 999
so all the rows are here displayed and
that's it for this video in the next
video i'm going to show you the
different attributes methods and
functions a data frame has in pandas
welcome back
in this video we're going to see some
basic attributes methods and functions
that we can use in pandas
but first let's learn what are each of
them
so first
attributes are values associated with an
object
and they are referenced by name using
that expression
so to get to an attribute we have to use
the dot sign
so for example below you can see that we
have a data frame named df and to get to
the columns we have to use the dot
columns so columns it's an attribute
and that's how we get this attribute of
this data frame
so
now we have a function a function is a
group of related statements that
performs a specific task so we've seen
functions before in python we've seen
some
python built-in functions like the max
that gets the maximum value of a list or
mean that gets the minimum value or
length that gets the length of the list
so those are some python building
functions that we can use in pandas too
and finally methods are
functions which are defined inside a
class body so we haven't talked anything
about classes because it's not the main
topic in this course so just keep in
mind that functions are inside a class
so when the creators of pandas build
pandas they use many classes and those
functions inside some classes are known
as methods so for example below you can
see the head method
and we've seen also the tail method and
some other methods so far
as a rule of thumb
when we use methods we have to write the
parentheses
but when we want to get access to
attributes we only write that that and
the name of the attribute
so the methods it's with that and
parentheses and the attribute is with
only that and the name of the attributes
so enough talk now let's write some code
in jupiter notebooks so here we're going
to use the same csv file we used in the
previous video
and we imported pendants as we did
before then we
read this csv file with the read
underscore csv method
and now we show the data frame simply by
writing the name of the data frame so
we've seen this before i'm just
uh reminding you and now we'll see some
basic attributes methods and functions
that we can use in pandas so first let's
check some attributes of this data frame
so first i'm going to copy the name of
the data frame
and now let's check so the first
attribute it's going to be the shape so
we've seen this before i believe and to
get to the attribute we write the dot
and then we write the name of the
attribute so
it's shape so df exams
that shape and we get the name of the
attribute the first is the number of
rows and the second is the number of
columns so let's go to the next
attribute
the next attribute is going to be the
index attribute and as you might expect
we have to write only the name of the
data frame then the dot and now
index and this is how we get the
index of this
data frame so as you can see this has
some form of range a range as you might
know
has three arguments
and actually two are
necessary the first is the start in this
case it starts in zero
and the second is the stop so the last
element and stops at 1 000
so this is uh true because here
my data frame starts with zero and
and finishes with
999 well it's 1000 because stopped one
before
1000
and here it increases by one so zero one
two and three and so on so the step is
one
so this is my my index attribute so now
let's continue and now let's get access
to the column attribute so to do so we
write the name of the data frame
and then we write the name of the
attribute so in this case
column and it has to be written
with s so in plural so we run this and
we get the
name of the columns so as you can see
here we have eight columns the gender
raised ethnicity and so on and we can
use this attribute even to modify the
name of the columns but we'll see that
later and now let's see how we can
obtain the data types of each column
to do so we have to use the
d types attribute so we write well the
name of the data frame again and then d
types
and this is gonna give us the
type of each column so the gender is
object and
actually from the gender to the
test preparation course are objects
while the math score reading score and
writing score are integers so numbers
by default anything that says object is
some kind of string so i'm going to
print this so you can see much better
so here is the data frame again
and as we've seen before from gender to
test preparation
has the type object and as we can see
here all of them are strings
so we can say that objects are the same
as strings here
and also
anything that has a score here
represent uh some kind of number so
that's why we get here integers so in
64. so these are the most common
attributes in appendage data frame now
let's review some methods so first let's
see the first five columns and as you
might know it's with the head method so
we only write the name of that attribute
sorry the name of the data frame
and then we write the head method so
head and parenthesis so we run this and
we obtain the first five rows so we can
also obtain some summary info of the
data frame by using the info method
so here we write the name of the data
frame info parenthesis and execute this
so here we have some information about
this
data frame and here we have again the
data type here
and also how many rows are non-null
so
as you can see here all the data that we
have in this data frame are non-null so
there isn't any empty data here in this
data frame okay now if we want to get
some
basic statistics of a data frame we have
to use the describe method
so we write the name of the data frame
and write describe
parenthesis
execute this so we run this code
and we have some basic statistics so
first the
count so this indicates how many rows
each column has
so
uh each of them has 1 000 rows
then we have the mean so it's basically
uh they assume each of the the data here
the numeric data and then divide it by
1000 because there are 1 000
rows
then the standard deviation the minimum
value
for example in math score the minimum
value was zero
then 25 percent represents the
percentiles so this is q1 25
q2 is 50
and q3 is
75
then we have the maximum value on each
score
on each exam and we see that the maximum
score is 100 on each of them so the
described method is a useful method
whenever we want to get
some basic statistics of the data frame
especially of the numerical data that we
have in our data frame okay now let's
see some functions that we can use in
pandas
we can use some built-in functions that
python has in pandas for example if we
want to get the length of a data frame
we only have to write len
and then inside parenthesis the name of
the data frame so we run this
and we obtain that the length of this
data frame is 1000
actually the length of a data frame
indicates only the number of rows
so here i made a mistake is rows
and this is how we obtain the number of
rows of a data frame
so also we can use other built-in
functions that python has like the max
function so we write max
then the name of the data frame we run
in this case we didn't get anything
anything
meaningful because
we get like a string but if we write
here
the index and we write max
as you might remember if we use this
this attribute we're going to get the
list of index
so if we use the max function we're
going to get the maximum or the highest
index here so run
n is 999
so we can also get the lowest index of a
data frame we only have to copy this
and instead of writing the max function
we write min so
in this case we get that minimum
index and is zero
so
now we can obtain the data type of
the data frame well the data frame has a
data stream type but we can verify that
using the type function so we write type
then
sorry write only the name of the data
frame
and we run so here as you can see
the type of this object is a data frame
and finally we can use a
common
function that is the round function so
we write only round
and this has two arguments so first the
object that we want to run
and in this case is our data frame and
the second argument is the number of
decimal points that we want to have so
in this case i want two decimal points
so we run this
and we're not gonna get this number of
decimal points in this particular
example because the
the numerical data we have here
it's uh
integers so they are not floats
so this doesn't have any effect but if
you have a data frame with float numbers
you can round those numbers using the
round function and that's it these are
the most basic attributes methods and
functions that we will see often in
pandas
all right now it's time to learn how to
select a column from a data frame
so here i have the same csv file we've
been using in the previous videos
and well let's import pandas and let's
read this csv file so i have this in the
same data frame
and i'm just showing the first five rows
so now to select one of the columns of
this data frame we have two options so
let's see the first option the first
option is using the square brackets this
is the preferred way to select a column
in pandas
and let's see how to select that gender
column so the first one here
so the first thing we have to do is to
write the name of the data frame in this
case df underscore exams and then open
square brackets so i open square
brackets and now we have to write the
name of the column so we open quotes and
now here i'm gonna copy
the name of this column and i'm gonna
paste it here
so we have here
the name of the data frame and then the
name of the column we want to select so
now we press ctrl enter to run this code
and as we can see we have the first
column of this data frame
so here we have this and as you might
expect this is an array so this is a 1d
array and as we discussed before
in previous videos 1d arrays are series
so we can verify if this is true so we
can do this with the
type function so i'm going to copy this
column this selection and now what we're
going to do is to use the type function
so we write type
then open parenthesis
and then inside parentheses we write the
object we want to evaluate so in this
case is this
and now we run this
and as you can see here we get a series
and series just like pandas data frames
have attributes and methods so we can
access those attributes and methods and
actually the attributes and methods
between
a series and the data frames are very
similar so for example if we want to get
the index attribute of this series we
only have to write that name of the
series and then write that and the name
of the attribute so index so we run this
and we get this index in form of a range
that starts with 0 and ends with
1000
so another method that share pandas in
series is the head method so we can also
get the first five rows by writing dot
head and parenthesis so as you can see
here we get the first five rows of this
series all right that's it for the first
syntax this is my favorite syntax and
actually most people use it because it's
the most practical and now is time to
see the second syntax to select a column
from a data frame so this syntax
involves writing that that sign which is
here
so let's say we want to get the same
gender column so we write the name of
the data frame
followed by that and the name of the
column so gender in this case we don't
need to open quotes and we don't need
the square brackets so we run this code
and we get the same series so it's here
and probably now you might be thinking
that this is more practical than the
first syntax but this syntax has some
pitfalls so now let me show you here
so what if you want to get
one column that has two words for
example what if you want to get let me
show you here
this column that has as name math score
so now let's try to get access to this
column i'm going to copy this column
name and now scroll down and and now
let's try so i'm going to write first
the name of the data frame and now the
dot so to get access to this or to
select this column we have to write the
column name so this is the column name
but as you can see
if i run this we get an error because
python doesn't work like that in python
when we have two words we usually add as
underscore so that's how python
understands this that this is a variable
but if it's like this python will not
understand what you're trying to do
however if you use the first syntax so
the square brackets you won't have this
problem so let me show you here now i'm
gonna write this
i'm gonna copy and now i'm gonna paste
it here and instead of having this only
that notation
i'm gonna open the square bracket so
open square brackets and then add the
quotes
so as you can see here the column names
has a string type you know python note
that this is a string and now if you
delete this dot sign and you execute
this you get this column without any
error so this is one of the bandages
that the square brackets has over the
that sign and that's it in this video we
learn how to select one column from a
data frame and in the next one we're
going to learn how to select two or more
columns from a data frame
okay in this video we're going to learn
how to select two or more columns from a
data frame
so as usual we're going to start by
importing pandas and reading the csv
file we've been using so far
so we execute these two lines of code
and we get here the data frame so what
we're going to do in this video is to
select two random columns from this data
frame
so first
let's pick some columns so i'm going to
select the gender column and also the
math score column
so
to select these two columns
we have to use the square brackets again
so here
in this case we have to use two square
brackets to select two or more columns
so to do this we have to write first the
name of the data frame
so it's df underscore
exams and now we open square brackets so
we write
one and two twice so
we have two pairs of square brackets and
inside we have to write the name of the
columns we want to select so
we said that we wanted the gender column
so we write gender and the second
column that we chose was that math score
so i opened these quotes and now i write
math score
so here i have these two columns and by
the way the order that we write these
columns is the same order that we're
going to get that data frame i mean we
can define the order of the columns
inside this square bracket so here we're
saying that first is the gender column
and second it should be the math score
column so now let's run this and as you
can see here we obtain first the gender
column and second the math score column
so here we can see that it's a data
frame and there are 999 rows so now we
can verify that this is actually a data
frame by using that type function so
let's check if this selection is a data
frame so now i'm going to copy this
in here
let's check out the data type of this
selection so here i paste it and now we
use the type function we open
this parenthesis and now we execute this
code and as you can see here we got that
this is a data frame
so here one little detail i want to tell
you is that when we use these two square
brackets or two pairs of square brackets
we're always gonna get a data frame but
when we use only single pair of square
brackets as we did in the previous video
we get a series so one pair of square
brackets is for a series and two pairs
of square brackets it's for a data frame
okay now to continue with the video
i'm gonna select two or more columns
using these two pairs of square brackets
so now let's choose the columns that
we're gonna get so in this case i'm
gonna get that gender column and all the
scores
that we have here so the math score
reading score and writing score
so to do so first i'm gonna copy this
first selection with it
to have it as a reference and now i'm
gonna paste it here
so here so far we have two columns so
let's add the two remaining columns so
here
an easy way to
to write these columns is just by
copying this in the data frame and here
we can paste it so instead of writing
those names we can just paste it here
now i delete and i put it inside quotes
so here inside quotes and here we have
it
so
here as i said before we can change the
order of the columns we just have to
for example here i cut this and let's
say we want to have the writing score
in the beginning so here i paste rating
score and now what we're going to get is
first the gender column then writing
score column and then the math score and
reading score columns so now let's run
this code and as you can see here we
have this data frame in the order that
we defined here
okay now you might be thinking
if there is a way to select two or more
columns using that that sign
so
let's check if that's possible here for
example let's say we want to get the
gender and the math score column using
that notation so here i have it and as
you can see here this doesn't look right
because it you have two strings
separated by a comma but you don't have
at least you don't have square brackets
this is probably gonna fail so let's
check i'm gonna run this code and as you
can see here we got an invalid syntax so
it's a syntax error so as you can see we
cannot select two or more columns with a
that sign and this is one of the
disadvantages that that sign has
over the
square brackets this is why most people
prefer to use the square brackets
instead of that that notation and that's
it for this video in this video we learn
how to select two or more columns from a
data frame
okay in this video we'll see different
ways to add a new column to a data frame
so here is the same student's
performance data frame and as you can
see we have three columns with scores
math score reading score and writing
score
so let's say we want to add a new score
so in this case let's add a language
score so to add a new column in
spreadsheets like google sheet or
microsoft excel we'll simply insert a
new column and that's it but in pandas
we have to use different methods or
different ways to allows us to insert a
new column so let's see how to do it
here
so first let's add a new column with a
scalar value
so a scalar value is simply a single
value and in this case it's the column
is going to have one single value so all
the rows is going to have the same value
so to do so we're going to have to
select this imaginary column because
this column doesn't exist so far so what
we're going to do is to select a column
as we will do with any other column so
first we write the name of the data
frame in this case df underscore exams
and then we open square brackets and
open quotes as we will do in any
column so here instead of for example
writing math score i'm going to copy
this
instead of selecting math score we have
to write the name of the
column we want to create so in this case
let's write language score so this is a
new column we want to create
and now we have to assign to this new
column we have to give it a new
value or a new scalar value in this case
i'm going to add a value of 70. so now
if we run this code we're gonna see that
nothing happens that if we
now show the data frame we're gonna see
that we have a new column and this
column is named language score and the
value that this column has is uh the
same value so it's 70 in all its rows so
we have 70 in row 0
and if we scroll down we're gonna see
that it's 70 in all the rows so even in
row
999 but it's a bit weird that in an exam
you will have
all the students with the same score so
what you will usually do is to add some
different values to
this column so to do this we have to use
arrays and to create arrays we have to
use numpy so here in the second way to
add a new column we're going to use
arrays
so in this case we have first to see how
many rows this
data frame has
so in this case it has 1 000 rows and
this is important because the number of
rows
has to match with the number of the ray
we're going to create so
let's create this array and first let's
import numpy so we write import
numpy
as
np so we run this code and now we
imported numpy so now we have to create
an array of 1000 elements
and to do so we're going to use a method
called range so it's written like this
orange and this give us a range of
numbers that start with the first
argument and that i'm going to write 0
and the last argument that in this case
it's going to be 1 000 so these are the
limits of my range so
i execute this and as you can see here
it starts with zero until 1000 so
to verify the
length of this
range we have to use the length function
so as you can see here the length is
1000 so the rate has 1000 elements so
now i'm going to assign this to a new
variable and i'm going to name this
variable language score so language
underscore score so we execute this and
here i was planning to see the length of
this
array so i quickly do it here as we did
it before so land and now we have the
length of the array
so now we have to add a new column to a
data frame with this array and to do
that we have only to
use the same way we did before so first
we
write the name of the data frame and
then we make the selection so this
uh selection is gonna be with the new
column well in this case it's not new
because we already created it but let's
imagine it's a new column so it's
language score
and now
we have to set the array to this column
so we write
language score
here
and we set it to this new column so now
to see the results we only show this
data frame
and as we can see
here
we have a new column and this new column
starts with 0 and it ends with 999
so it doesn't have a single value
anymore but now it has a range of values
and now there is a little detail we have
to take care of
so scores are supposed to be between
0 to 100 and we have here from 0 to
999 and also here we have a sequence of
numbers so it's from zero and then one
and it increases by one and usually in
scores you will see that students have
random scores so we have to create here
an array with random numbers and to do
that we have to use numpy again but here
we have to use a different method in
this case the method is named
random.brand
int
so let's write it here np dot
random that run
and then
int so the first argument is the lowest
value of these random numbers and by the
way these are
random integer numbers because scores
are usually integer numbers and in this
case i'm going to set this this to 1
and the second score
is the highest number or value in these
random numbers and i'm going to set it
to 100
and the third argument is the size in
this case we want a rate of 1000
elements so we set the size to 1000
now we execute this we run this and i'm
not gonna see this
uh rate again i'm just going to check
that it has the length we want by using
the length function and here we have
1000 elements so now let's
create a new variable and store this in
the variable so here this is going to be
int and then
language underscore score
and this is going to be our
new variable
so here one little detail you should
know is that the first argument is
inclusive and the last one is exclusive
so this means that if we hear let's say
we get the minimum value of this
new uh array
we're gonna get that the minimum value
is one because this first argument is
inclusive which means that it can be
included in this new array
however if we print now the maximum
value of this
array
we're going to get that 100 is not there
because it's exclusive which means that
this second argument shouldn't be
included in this array okay finally
let's insert this
random integer numbers in the new column
that we created so we have to
just use the same
way we did before
so here i copy and now i paste it so
here instead of assigning this language
underscore score
i'm going to use this int
language underscore score so here i'm
going to
run this code and as you can see here we
have this
the same column and we have now
this data that is random random integer
numbers from the row 0 to the row
999 so now this new data looks more like
scores like real scores because
these are random numbers and these are
between 0 and 99 and that's it now one
more little detail i want to share with
you is how to create random float
numbers because before we created random
integer number but if for some reason
you want to create random float numbers
there is a way how to do it with numpy
so we only write np then that random
then that uniform
and the arguments are the same so the
minimum value then the maximum value
then the size which is 1 000
then you run this and well it's similar
to the one we got before but now we have
float numbers and that's it in this
video we learn different ways to add a
new column to a data frame
all right now it's time to see some
operations we can perform on data frames
so here we have the same data frame df
underscore exams and here we can apply
some common operations to the numerical
columns like math score reading score
and writing score
so let's see how to do this
in pandas so first we're gonna see how
to make operations in columns so our
first task is to calculate the total sum
of a column so let's pick first the math
score and let's calculate the sum of
this column so to do that we have first
to select a column
and as you might remember to select a
column first we have to write the name
of the data frame in this case df
underscore exams then we open square
brackets and then write either single or
double quotes
then we have to write the name of the
column
and in this case it's this one math
score
this is the column we want to select
and now instead of selecting we're going
to perform a
operation so in this case i want to
calculate the total sum of this column
and we have to use the sum method so we
write dot sum
and parenthesis and this is how you
calculate the total sum of this column
so to verify this
we run this code
and here we got 66 000 and this is the
total
sum of this math column
great now we can make some other
operations you will do in excel for
example we can
calculate the the number of rows using
the account method so here we can easily
do that i'm just going to copy this one
and now instead of writing the sum
method we write count
so here count and now let's see
so we see 1 000 rows and yeah this is
correct because this data frame has 1
000 rows so now we can calculate the
mean of this
math score column we have to copy this
one now paste it instead of writing
count we have to write mean
and here we got the average value of
this math score column so to get the
average we have to sum all the rows in
this math score column and then divide
it by the total number of
rows in this case 1000 and this is how
you get this mean value
then we can get other uh other
operations using
the method so here for example we can
get the standard deviation
by writing std
so we execute this
and the standard deviation of this math
score column is 15 and we can get also
the maximum and minimum value let's do
it quickly here so first the max
and then the mean value you can actually
do it with the python built-in function
but we can also do it with the methods
so here i run and as you can see here
the minimum value of the math score is 0
and the maximum is 100 okay now i'm
going to show you a quickly way to make
the same calculations using the
described method
i think we saw the described method in
previous videos but in case you don't
remember it i'm going to write here
uh the name of actually we only need the
name of the data frame we don't we don't
need the name of a specific column we
only need that name of the data frame
and now we can use the describe method
so we write that describe with
parentheses
and now we got
like a summary table with some important
statistical values and here we have the
count that mean the standard deviation
the minimum and maximum value and as you
can see here we got all of this with one
method okay so far so good now instead
of making operations in columns we're
going to learn how to make operations in
rows
so now let's calculate
let's say
the sum of the math score reading score
and writing score
to do so we have to make some selections
and in this case we have to make some
independent selections so to show you
i'm going to copy the name of these
three columns
i copied it and now i paste it here
and now we have a math score
reading score and writing score so now
let me
delete that sign and
now we have to make some independent
selections so first we write the name of
that data frame so df exams and now to
make the selection we open square
brackets in quotes
so now let me do this quickly in the
orders now here
so i open square brackets and now let me
do it here too
and now it's ready so here we made some
independent selections and now to make
uh to calculate the sum in a row we have
to use the plus sign so here the plus
operator
we have to write it here and here so
basically here we're making
uh
some in each row so to verify this we
run this code and as you can see here we
got the sum of the scores column
so here let's verify
fast the sum of the first row and it's
72 plus 72 plus 74 so
72 with 72 is
144
and with 74 is
218 so here we have it
and it's
correct so now
let's do something else so now instead
of just
summing these three
rows or actually these three columns
what we're going to do is to calculate
the average to get like an average score
so here let me copy this and now here
we're going to calculate the average by
summing this
and then dividing this by three so this
is how we calculate the score and now
let's assign this result to a new column
to do so we only write equal and then
as you might remember from previous
lessons
we have to add a new column by writing
the name of this column so we do that
writing the name of the data frame
and then
making like a selection so we open
square brackets then open quotes and
here we write the name of the column
that we want to create
so this is the same as we did in
previous lessons where we added a new
column
so in this case i'm gonna name this new
column as average
and i'm gonna execute this
and now to verify that this new column
was created i'm gonna show this data
frame here
below and here is our data frame so now
in the last column you can see that
there is
an column name average and it has the
average value of this math score written
score and writing score and now here we
can control the number of decimals we
can just use the
round function
and write the number of decimals we want
to get so in this case i want only two
decimals so i run this
and as you can see here
our data frame looks much better
because we only have two decimals and
that's it in this video we'll learn
different ways to make operations in
columns and rows on data frames
all right now let's have a look at the
value counts method
so so far
we have seen how to
count the number of rows in a data frame
so for example if we want to count the
number of rows in the gender column we
either use the length function so we
write length then the number or the name
of the data frame
and we only have to write the name of
the column
so as you might remember this give us
the number of rows and we can also use
the account method
so here we write count and we get the
number of rows but what if we want to
count the gender elements by category so
female or male what if we want to know
how many female and how many male
elements are in this gender column
so this is when the value counts comes
in handy
so we can use this method to count each
category of the column so to use this
method we only have to write the name of
the data frame
followed by the column that we want to
count so in this case is that gender
column
and then we have to use the value
underscore counts method
as you can see here
so now we execute this and as you can
see here we have
not only the total rows in this gender
column but now it's divided by category
so we have that there is 518
females and
482 males so this is how the data is
spread in the gender column so now we
can do more with the value counts method
so we can get the percentage that each
category represents in the whole column
so here i'm going to copy this
and now to calculate the percentages
also known as relative frequency we have
to add an argument named
normalize so we write normalize equal to
true
and then we execute this and as we can
see here female represent 51
of the total observations in the gender
column while male 1 represents 48
of the total observations so as you can
see here the value count method is
useful when you want to have a look at
the data by category okay now let's see
another example and in this case let's
pick a different column so here i'm
going to choose this parental level of
education column i copy this
and now let's
calculate uh let's count the elements by
category so here i'm gonna write the
name of the data frame the
exams and now i open square brackets
quotes and here i
paste this
column now to count the elements by
category in this column we use the value
underscore counts method
so we run this code and here you can see
how the data is divided in this column
so most people have some college level
of education
while just a few people have a master's
degree and now if we want to get the
percentages that represent each category
we again use the normalized
argument so we write normalize equal to
true and now we're gonna get the
percentages
so we can see the percentages and if we
want to round this to two decimals we
use the round method so we write that
round
parenthesis and now two decimals and as
you can see here we round it to two
decimals and that's it now you know how
to use the value counts method
okay in this video we're gonna see how
to sort a data frame using the sort
underscore values method
first let's import and read the csv file
that we've been working with in this
tutorial
and now let's sort the data frame so
here we have the data frame and as you
might remember it's it has these three
numerical
columns and now i'm going to sort it
using one of these columns so let's use
the sort underscore values method and
first i'm going to write the name of the
data frame which is tf underscore exams
and then write sort underscore values
now i open parenthesis and now i can use
this
help here
and as you can see the only mandatory
argument is pi so
we can use this one by and this one we
have to specify
the name of the column we want to sort
by so in this case i want to sort by the
math score so i'm choosing this
numerical column to start with
so i'm going to write math score
actually i'm going to copy this one and
paste it here so by math score
and sorting this data frame is as simple
as that now we can run this code and as
you can see here the data frame was sort
ascending by default so it starts with 0
and it ends with 100 in the math score
so this is how the sort underscore
values behave by default
and here one little detail you don't
need to specify the
byte word we can omit it and we run this
and as you can see here it still works
so here we can modify that default
behavior of the sort underscore values
method we only have to add a new
argument and is that ascending argument
so let me show you here i'm going to
copy this one first and show you here so
in this case we're going to sort
descending by the same column so we only
write
comma and then we specify the sending
argument so we write ascending equal to
and here i want to show you something in
this little help here here the sending
is set to true by default this means
that is ascended by default but we can
change this default behavior by
setting ascending equal to false and
that's what we're gonna do here
ascending equal to false so it means
descending
and now i'm gonna
run this one and as you can see here is
sort descending by the math score column
so here it starts with 100 and it ends
with zero but that's not all we can do
much more with the sort underscore value
method so first i'm going to show you
here how to sort by two different
columns so here let's
copy and paste this one so in this case
we're gonna sort descending by multiple
columns
so instead of writing only math score
we're going to add here one more column
and it's gonna be the reading score
column so here i copy this one
i'm gonna copy and paste it here but
first we have to add the square brackets
because as you might remember when we
write two or more columns we need the
square brackets now i write comma and i
paste this written score now i add
quotes and that's it that's everything
you have to do to sort by multiple
columns now i'm going to run this one
and as you can see here it was sort
descending first by the math score
column and then by the written score
column so the priorities are set here in
the
list that we
include here so first is the math score
column first priority and the second
priority is the written score column and
that's what you can see here
now i'm gonna show you a little detail
here let me copy the df underscore exams
and if i print this one you can see that
the changes we made
weren't updated so
this here the math score column has the
original values this happens because the
sort underscore values method like many
other pandas method only creates a copy
of the data frame so here we obtain a
copy this one is a copy but it doesn't
update the values of the data frame
unless we add a new argument which is
the in place argument so i'm gonna show
you here but first i'm going to delete
this
df underscore exams and now i'm going to
copy this one and show you how to update
the values of this data frame so here
i'm going to copy
those are the same values but now i'm
going to add a new argument which is the
in place argument so here we write in
place
equal to and now i'm going to show you
the default value so here the default
value of implies is false this means
don't update the data frame but only
create a copy but if we set it to true
it means update this data frame so here
i'm going to set it to true to update
the data frame so here i write true
and now i run this and apparently
nothing happens but if now we print that
df underscore exams data frame we're
gonna see that we have that data frame
sorted in case you don't want to add
that in place argument and you want to
update the values of the data frame you
have another option that we used before
which is overwriting the values of this
data frame so for example you can only
delete that in place argument and write
df
underscore exams equal to this so this
is overwriting the values but in this
case we're not gonna do that we're gonna
add that in place argument as you can
see here
finally we're gonna see how to sort but
now not with numerical data but with
text so as you can see here we before
sort this data frame by the math score
column and this one has this numerical
data but in this case we're going to
sort it by the arrays ethnicity which
has this text so we're going to sort
this one so first we're supposed to get
group 1 and then group b c d e and so on
so let's do this here i'm going to
scroll down and first we have to write
the name of the data frame
followed by the
sort underscore values method and now
specify the name of the column so here
i'm going to copy
raise ethnicity
here
let me copy here and
it's done
now i have the name of the column i'm
gonna set to
ascending to true and now that new
argument we have to add to sort this is
that key
so i add key then equal to in this case
we're gonna use the lambda function i'm
not sure if you're familiar with the
lambda function
but it works similar to an average
function we've seen before in the
python crash course but in this case
it's gonna behave a little bit different
so let me show you here first you have
to use the lambda keyword so we write
only lambda and now we should write that
object that is supposed to return in
this case i'm gonna write call that
stand for column
and then we have to
write column and specify the operation
we have to make over this
variable so in this case i want to
write column or call and then access the
string attribute so i write that str and
then use the lower method
so what we're saying here is get the
string values of the column and then
transform it to lowercase so here we get
that textual data in lowercase and with
these three arguments we're saying sort
the values inside the race ethnicity
column and sorted ascending and then
sort the textual data of this column in
lowercase
so here we have this a b c d e in
upper case but we're going to get it in
lower case and sorted by this text data
so now let's run this one and let's see
the results
so as you can see here we have this
rates ethnicity column and its order
ascending so here we got the a and b and
c and d and so on and that's it these
are the different ways to sort a data
frame using the sort underscore values
method
welcome back
in this video we're gonna see different
ways to make pivot tables if you're an
excel user probably you made many people
tables in the past
in pandas we can also make pivot tables
and in this case we use two different
methods the pivot method and the pivot
underscore table method in this video
we're gonna see the difference between
the two of them so first let's see
what's the pivot method so the pivot
method reshapes data based on columns
values
and it doesn't support data aggregation
so this means that this is not the
regular pivot table you will see in
excel
because you can only reshape data with
the pivot method and you cannot do
anything else to explain you better what
the pivot method does i'm going to show
you an example
so here we have a little data frame and
this one has six rows and four columns
and as you can see here there are many
duplicate values for example in the
column foo the one value is repeated at
least twice and the same goes for the 2
value also in the column bar you can see
that the a b and c
is duplicated so when we have this type
of data frame we can reshape it to have
a different view and to make a better
analysis in this case we can use the
pivot method as i'm going to show you
right now
you only have to write the name of the
data frame followed by the pivot method
and then specified
three arguments so the first one is the
index in this case i'm going to reshape
this data frame choosing the column foo
as an index this means that the column
foo
will be in the position where is right
now the numbers from 0 to 5
on the left
next you have to define that column so
these are the new columns that we're
going to see in our new data frame the
one that we're going to reshape so in
this case i'm selecting the data inside
the bar column as new columns
this means that a b and c will be the
new columns in our new data frame and
finally we have to choose the values we
wish to show in this new data frame so
in this case i'm choosing the best
column so all the values inside there
will be shown in our new data frame so
this is the column that i'm selecting
and now i'm going to show you the result
of this
pivot method so here it is and as you
can see here we have the
foo in the index as i told you before
and the a b and c
that are data from the bar column now
are columns in this new data frame also
all the data inside this best column is
the only data that is displayed in this
reshaped data frame and now let's see
what is sorted this way so why 1 is here
2 is here 3 is here and so on so here
the value is defined by the index or row
and the column so between 1 index 1 and
column a is one and why that happens
because if we go to the
our previous data frame or the original
data frame that is here we can find that
here is one
a and the value that corresponds to that
pair is the number one
so let's pick another one for example
five here we have two and b
and if we go here to our original data
frame
we have that 2 and b the value that
corresponds that pair is 5 so that's why
this value is here and that's how this
new data frame was reshaped okay and
finally we have the pivot underscore
table method and this one creates a
spreadsheet style pivot table so this is
similar to the pivot table that we will
find in microsoft excel for example and
this one supports data aggregation and
to explain you more about the pivot
underscore table method as well as the
pivot method we're gonna see some
examples in the next video and this time
we're gonna write some code so you can
understand much better what we're doing
all right now it's time to see how the
pivot method works in action in pandas
so first as usual we import pandas as pd
so here i import this library and then
we're going to use a different data set
to work with this pivot method
so to read this data set we use the pd
read underscore csv
method and inside parenthesis we write
the name of this
data set so in this case is
gdp that's csv that you can find
in the notes of this video so this is
the new data set and now let's have a
look i'm going to run this one
and as you can see here we have data
about gdp per capita that is in this
column
and basically this is how the gdp
grow over the years for each country
so here i'm going to tell you which are
the columns we're going to use for this
example
so first we're going to use the country
column that contains data about
different countries
then we're going to use that year column
that well contains different years and
that gdp
per capita that it's in this column
so basically what we want to
do in this exercise is to obtain a
different view of our original data set
so this data set that we're reading here
with pandas
has this
view but we want to get a different view
to have a better analysis so the goal of
this exercise is to see the evolution of
the gdp per capita over the years for
each country and then we're going to put
the country names in the columns
so the only data we're going to show in
our new data frame is going to be the
gdp per capita that it's here
so i'm going to show you now this with
code and let's write it here but first
let's assign a
variable to this
data frame so here i'm going to write df
underscore gdp
so this is the name of my data frame and
now
i'm going to show it and it's here so
now i'm gonna copy this
data frame and to use the pivot method
i'm going to paste this one and now
write that
pivot
now we open parentheses and now as you
might remember from the previous video
we have to introduce three different
arguments and if you don't remember the
three different arguments we have to
introduce here you can only press the
shift and tap
keys on your keyboard and you will get
this and here you can see the three
arguments i'm talking about so first we
have to write the index argument
so we write index
and as i told you before
i want the
year column to be the index of my new
reshaped data frame so i'm going to set
this year as the index of my new data
frame so right here here next we write
comma and press shift and tap to show
this so the second argument is the
columns so we write columns then equal
and open quotes so here as i told you
before i want the countries here listed
in the country column
i want each country to be an independent
column so for example here
let's say we have the united states so i
want the united states to be column
number one then column number two china
then australia then spain and so on so
each country should have one independent
column
so that's what we want and to get that
we have to set the country column
here to the columns
argument so here country and that's it
now again shift plus tab to show this
window here and now the third argument
is values so here i'm going to write
values equal to
open
quotes
and here the only data i want to show
here in my new data frame is going to be
the gdp per capita which is
the one that is here and now i'm going
to copy this one
and paste it here
so remember our goal our goal is to see
the evolution of the gdp per capita over
the years for all the countries listed
here in this column so here we're gonna
execute this code and let's see the
result so here control enter and as you
can see here
i have the
new view of this data frame and it looks
much better it's more readable because
we can see the gdp
evolution over the years for each
country so now let's verify if
everything is correct
so here we have the index year and here
we have the year as index so
everything's fine then the columns
should be country and now we have each
country in the columns so
it's correct next the values are the gdp
per capita and yeah we have here
the intersection between the row and a
column is a value that corresponds to
the gdp per capita of that country in
that year so everything is working fine
and there you have it this is how the
pivot method works in pandas
okay now let's see how the pivot
underscore table method
works in pandas
so in this case we're going to work with
a different data set and to read it
we're going to use the method pd read
underscore excel because in this case
the data set is not a csv file but an
excel file so we use read underscore
excel for an excel file so in this case
the name of this data set is
super market
underscore sales that
xlsx
and this is what we're going to see
after you run this
and here you can see that we have
different columns about uh
a specific person bought in a
supermarket and here well we have
the
branch the city the gender and different
data
so here to
make a pivot table we're gonna first
name this data frame and i'm gonna name
it df underscore sales okay now i'm
gonna show it here
and okay now it's here okay the goal of
this task is to see how much female and
male
spend their money in this supermarket so
to do that we're gonna use the pivot
table method in pandas so first i'm
gonna copy this data frame and now i'm
gonna paste it here
and now we're gonna make a pivot table
and add an output function because
remember that the pivot underscore table
method allows us to add an aggregate
function and the pivot method doesn't
support that so we're gonna use the
pivot underscore table this time
and now we're gonna introduce some
important arguments so the first one is
that index
and in this case if we want to see how
much male and female spend in this
supermarket
the index is going to be the gender so
here i'm going to copy gender here and
it's going to be here index equal to
gender so this is the first
necessary argument and the second one is
going to be
the aggregate function so we have to
write a double g
f u and c and then equal to and then
write the aggregate function we want to
perform so in this case is going to be a
sum so we write
sum and now everything is ready so what
we're supposed to get here is the
information about
the sales here in this data frame but
now divided by gender so we have the
female category and then the male
category so let's
verify this i'm going to run this one
and as you can see here we have this
summary table or pivot table and now
it's divided by gender so we can see how
much female
spent here in the total column and also
how much male spend
also in the total column and here in the
quantity column we can see how many
products they bought how many products
female and male bought in this
supermarket and one detail you might
have noticed is that only the columns
that contain numerical data are
displayed here so for example here
branch and city that contain
only text aren't here in this pivot
table because here in the aggregate
function argument we indicated that we
want to sum and when we sum values we
cannot sum uh text but only numerical
data so only the columns that have
numerical data are displayed in this new
pivot table okay that's our first pivot
table and we can do even more for
example we
can select a pair of columns that we're
interested in so let's say we only care
about the quantity and the total column
so we want only those columns so
we
can get that i'm gonna copy this one
and to show you how to get only those
two columns
i'm going to
add a new argument so here
i'm going to write
and in this case the name of that
argument is values so i read values
equal to and in this case i'm going to
select the quantity and the total
columns so i open square brackets
because i'm going to select two or more
columns and inside i write the name of
the column so first quantity
right here and then
total so here too
so
we're gonna get the same
uh pivot table but in this case only the
quantity and the total columns are gonna
be shown in this table so i'm gonna
execute this one and here i got an error
because i didn't include this comma so
i'm gonna add it here
and now everything should be fine and
yeah
we got the same pivot table but only the
quantity and total columns are displayed
here and here we can clearly see that
female spend more than male in this
supermarket
but we can get even more detail here so
far we know that female spend
167 000
in this supermarket but with pivot
tables we can even know
in which product lines this money is
spent so let me show you here
we can see
how the money is spent in this product
line column so we only have to add a new
argument to this pivot table method so
i'm going to show you here
first we copy this and now i'm gonna
paste it here
and we're going to make a pivot table
that says how much male and female spent
in each category or well product line
so we add a new argument and this one is
going to be the columns argument so i
write columns then open quotes i add the
comma and here i write the name of this
column that is product line so i
scroll up i copy this column and then
we're gonna see in which category is to
spend the money so health and beauty or
sports and so on so now i scroll down
and here i paste it
and before i run this code here we only
want to display the total because we
only want to see where the money goes
not the quantity so
only total so i delete the square
brackets too and with total we're gonna
see where the money goes divided by
gender
so here i run because it's ready
and now
as you can see here we can see how much
female and male spend in each product
line so we can quickly see for example
that female spend
more money
on fashion accessories than mail and
that kinda makes sense
and also in sports women spend or female
spend more money than male so we could
easily see all of that by using the
pivot underscore table method in pandas
and this is similar to the pivot table
you will find in excel and that's it
that's how you make a pivot table in
pandas
alright before showing you how to make
visualizations with pandas first we have
to check the data set and also we have
to make a pivot table so we can easily
make the plots with pandas later
so first we have to import pandas to
read this csv file
and well i have these import pandas as
pd so we just
run this code and now let's read this
new data set so as you might remember
to read a csv file we have to use the
read underscore csv method so we write
pd
dot rate
underscore csv
and then we write the name of the csv
file so in this case the name is
population
and i'm gonna use this population
underscore total that's csv so i press
stop to get this
the name so we have now the name
and now i'm going to assign this to a
new variable so
the variable is going to be
df
underscore population
underscore raw
so this uh raw data and now
we're gonna have a first look at this
data set so i paste this and now i'm
going to run these two
and now we have this data frame so here
as you can see we have the population of
many countries throughout the years so
for example we have china here united
states
and india
so we have the population and here i
wrote the name ro because this data set
was extracted using some web scraping
techniques and then it wasn't modified
so now we have to make some changes to
reshape this data frame so we
make it easy for us to make
visualizations with pandas later
so what we have to do here is to make a
pivot table to reshape this data frame
and that's what we're going to do here
below
so we're going to make a pivot table and
we're going to use the pivot method so
as you might remember the pivot method
returns a reshaped data frame organized
by given index column values
but it's a pivot without aggregation
so this is what we want so we only want
to reshape this data frame
so we're going to start by dropping null
values
so we do that by writing
the name of the data frame and now i'm
going to just copy the name and i paste
it here
and now to drop null values we have to
use the drop n a method so i write drop
n a
and then we have to run this and as you
can see here we have the result and it's
a copy from this
data frame but if we want to save the
changes that we make to the data frame
we have two options the first option is
to use that in place
argument so i write in place and then
set this to true so if we do this and we
run all the changes that we make to the
data frame are gonna be saved and the
second option is to
do something like this to override the
content inside this data frame so
we do something like this we write df
underscore population underscore raw is
equal to the same data frame but that
drop in a so we're overwriting the
content inside this
data frame so i'm gonna
choose the first option just to reduce
some code so i write in place equal to
true and now i run and this new data
frame shouldn't have any new values okay
now it's time to
make this pivot table so first i'm going
to show you what i'm going to do so we
have a better idea before writing the
code so here we have the original data
frame and what we're going to do is to
reshape this data frame
so i want the year to be in the index so
that your column i want it to be here in
the index instead of 0 1 and so on
and then i want the country
column or the country the values inside
the country column i want it to be here
in the columns so for example i want
china here in one column then united
states in another column and then india
in another column
and i want the population data
inside the data i wanted this to be the
only data here so to do that we have to
use the pivot method and that's what
we're going to do here below so let's do
it here
so first we have to write the name of
the data frame which is this one and
then write dot pivot then we open
parenthesis
in here
let's see the arguments that this pivot
method accepts so i press shift and tap
to get this
helpful
let's call it cheat sheet and now we
have the arguments that this pivot
method accepts so first is the index
then the column and then the values
so as i told you before
the index i want it to be the year
column so we have to write index
equal to
open quotes and i write here
then coma and let's check another
argument so the next argument is the
columns so i want the columns to be the
country so the data inside the country
columns so here i write columns
then i open
quotes and here i write country
so country
and now the last one i think is values
and yeah it's values
so i want the values to be the
population data so let me see if that's
correct and yeah it's here so population
and i'm going to press enter here so it
looks much better and now population is
here so i have the three arguments the
index the columns and the values and now
i'm going to reshape my original data
frame so here i
press ctrl enter now as you can see here
we have the countries in the columns so
here we have many countries uh it's
from the first country afghanistan
to andorra argentina uruguay and many
other countries
so we have also the year so it's here
the year uh from 1955
to 2020
so we can see here the evolution of the
population throughout the years for
all the countries in this data set
but as you can see there are many
countries so what we can do here is to
select just some countries so we can
simplify our visualizations later
in pandas so here
i'm going to select some columns but
first i'm gonna name this new data frame
i'm gonna give it a name
so i'm gonna name it df
underscore
pivot
so this is my new data frame
now i'm going to
rearrange this and now it looks much
better so now i'm going to run this and
now let's select some countries so i
copy this pivot
data frame and now we open square
brackets double square brackets to
select two or more columns
and here let's write some countries so
first united states
then let's say
india
then china
two more countries indonesia
and last but not least brazil
so here we have the five countries so i
run here
and
we have these five countries and the
population from 1955 to 2020
so great now we simplify this data frame
and now i'm going to overwrite the
content inside the data frame df
underscore pivot
and i'm going to write here
df pivot
equal to df pivot and with this
selection so i'm overwriting the content
so i press ctrl enter
and our new df underscore pivot
is here so we have it here and now i'm
going to show it to you
and this is our new
df underscore pivot data frame and
that's it now our data is ready so we
can use it to make great visualizations
with pandas and that's what we're gonna
do in the next video
okay now it's time to make some
visualizations with pandas and here i
have the data frame that we created this
is the pivot table we created in the
previous video and as you can see here
we have five countries in the columns
and here we have the year in the index
from 1955 to 2020
so what we're going to do now is to make
our first visualization so i scroll down
here and the first one is gonna be line
plots so here first to make this
visualization i'm gonna copy the name of
the data frame
and i paste it here
so now to make plots with pandas we have
to use the plot method so we write that
plot
and now i open parenthesis
and one necessary argument we need to
introduce is the kind argument so i
write kind
now equal to
and here i have to write a kind of plot
we want to make so in this case it's a
line plot so we write line
and this is actually the
mandatory argument we have to introduce
here and now we can run this code so i
press ctrl enter and as you can see here
i have the line plot so in this line
plot we can quickly see the evolution of
the population throughout the years for
example china and india
which are green and orange lines they
had some
fast growing population
while united states indonesia and brazil
are they have a
lower population and also the population
didn't change so much in the past 50
years here we can add more arguments to
this plot method to customize this line
plot
so here we can introduce another
argument
which is the x label
and this x label is what you can see
here
here uh when we created this line plot
uh by default it was
assigned this year label but we can
change it so for example let's say we
have we want to write here but now with
capital letter so we write here here
and now let's say we want to add a new
label
here in the y-axis so here we have only
to write
y label
and then equal to open quotes in here we
have to write the name we want so in
this case i'm gonna write only
population
and finally we can also add a title
so we can add any title we want in this
case i'm gonna write
uh well the name of the argument first
title
then equal to
and then the name of the title is gonna
be
let's say population
uh from 1955
and to 2020. so this is the title
so let's run this and now as you can see
here we got the title population 1955 to
2020 and the x label and y label
were modified too finally we can add one
more argument in this case the argument
is the
size of the figure so to change the size
of this
figure we can add the argument name
fixed size
and this is a tuple so we have to open
parentheses
and now to edit the size we have to add
two
arguments the first is the size of the
x-axis and the second the size of the
y-axis so in this case i'm going to set
it to a
and then four which means that the
x-axis is going to be
large
while the
y axis is gonna be short
so here
i'm gonna run this code and let's check
it out so here the figure has a
different size
and that's how you can customize this
line plot
okay now let's make a bar plot with
pandas so the first thing we have to do
is to select only one year so the bar
plot only accepts just one year and we
can plot there the population of
different countries so let's select one
year of this data frame we have before
so i'm gonna copy the name of the data
frame
so you can check it out again so this is
the data frame and we're going to select
one year
so to do that we have to use the index
attribute and then that is in method so
first i'm going to show you
the index method in case you don't
remember so here that index
sorry again that index attribute
allows us to see all the index in this
data frame so we have here from 1955 to
2020.
so that's what the index attribute does
and now if we
use that
is
in method
we can filter out some
index
so here let's say we want to select only
that 2020.
so i copy 2020
and now
here
i write equal to and
first i'm gonna make the selection
so it's here
and now i'm going to show you what's the
result so here i press ctrl enter and
the result is this little data frame
that only contains the population in the
year 2020
so this is important because the bar
plot is supposed to show only the
population in this year
so here we have it and now
what we're going to do is to
name this data frame so here we write
equal to
and then let's give it a name so i'm
going to name it
df underscore pivot underscore 2020 so
here i press ctrl enter
and now
i'm going to show this new data frame
well again here and here one little
detail i have to tell you is that when
we make bar plots we have to
put text data
in the index so here the name of the
countries should be in the index so to
do that we
have to use the transpose
method so this transpose allows us to
switch rows and columns and vice versa
so here we can easily do that by writing
the data frame the name of the data
frame you know
that t so if now we run this code
we can see here that we have this so now
the year 2020 is in the column and not
in the index anymore
and the country names are in the index
here so this is the format we need to
have before making the bar plot
so now i'm going to overwrite the
content in this data frame so
i write df underscore pivot underscore
2020 equal to this
same data frame but that t so here
i run this and now it's time to make the
bar plot so here i copy the name of the
bar plot and now i use the plot method
so i write plot again
open parenthesis and
the first argument is the kind so i open
quotes and we write bar
so now it's ready and we can run it so
as you can see we have a basic bar plot
and it has some default values like
uh the name of this x label
and also the default color is blue and
we can customize this bar plot a bit
more for example i want a different
color so i write the color argument and
then open
these quotes and let's say i want it to
be orange so i write orange
and also we can change the
x and y label
actually i can copy this here so i can
save some time here so x label and wire
label are here and let's
paste it here
so x and y label
and finally i can add also the title
which
was here
so i copy and paste it but in this case
the title is a bit different because in
this case it's not from 1855 to 2020 but
it's only 2020.
so here i have only 2020 and now let's
run this to see the results so you can
see here we have a title the x and y
label
and the bar plot is in orange
so that's how you customize the bar plot
all right so far so good now let's go
one step further by making bar plots
grouped by end variables
so
here we have to select a group of gears
to make these bar plots group by end
variables so i'm going to copy this code
we used before
to select only the year 2020
i'm gonna copy this
and in this case i'm not going to select
only one year
but a group of years
so let me show you here instead of
choosing only 2020
i'm going to show you the pivot table
again so you can easily understand so
instead of choosing only 20 20 i'm gonna
choose
some other years here so i'm gonna
delete this
and i'm going to write it here so let's
say 1980 1990 then 20 then 2000
and 2010 and well finally 2020. so we
have a group of years here and we're
selecting this
using the index and is in
method
so here i'm going to give it a different
name in this case since it's a sample
i'm going to write df underscore pivot
underscore sample
now i'm going to
first i'm going to show you this one so
you can see what this looks like so now
we have five countries and now five
years so now
i'm going to assign this to
my
data frame so df underscore pivot
underscore sample i run this and now we
have this new data frame
so it's time to make this grouped bar
plot so here we write the name of the
data frame and then the plot method
so we write that plot
and now let's add the first argument
which is kind and equal to bar
now we run this and as you can see here
we have the
the plots or the bar plots grouped by
deer so here's 1980 in
1990 and so on and you can also add the
same arguments we added here so for
example i can add the
x and y label so i can do it here i'm
gonna do it fast so here
i run and as you can see here we have
the
we modified the x and y label and that's
it that's how you make bar plots with
pandas
okay in this video we're going to learn
one of the most common charts that we
can make in tenders and actually any
other visualization tool and these are
pie charts so before we make this pie
chart first let's
give a look to the
the data frame we're going to use in
this case to make a pie chart we're
going to use the same data frame we used
for
making the bar plot because it follows
the same logic so here i'm going to copy
the data frame we created for the bar
plot which is this one df underscore
pivot underscore 2020
so this is
what we created before by using the
index attribute and that is in method so
here i'm going to copy this
and now i'm gonna show you here so so
you can remember what's inside this data
frame and it's here
so here as you can see
uh we have the column 2020 and the
countries are in the index
so everything is fine that's what we
need that's the format we need for
making the pie chart but there is one
little thing we have to modify and this
is the column name because now it's 20
20 and this is a number it's
actually i think it's an integer so
it's not a good practice to have numbers
in columns so what we have to do is to
make this a string and to do that we use
that rename method so we write
that rename
open
parenthesis and now we use the
columns argument so we write columns
then open these curly braces
and now we write the name of the column
we want to change which is 2020 and
we're going to make this integer
value into a string so we open quotes
and write 2020. so apparently they are
the same but the green one is a integer
and the red one is a string
so now to make to save these changes i'm
going to write in place equal to true
and i'm going to run this so now we can
make the plot
here i'm going to write the name of the
data frame and now i'm going to use the
plot method so here i write that plot
so the first argument is kind
and here i write pi so
the kind is pi and now i run this
and here i forgot to include that y
argument and i'm going to write here
so the y argument is supposed to have
the data so in this case i'm going to
show you here again the data frame
so the data
is here in 2020 so we should write here
2020.
so i'm gonna delete this
and here in the y
argument you write the column that has
the data so that's what we did so now i
run this
and now we finally have our pie chart so
here is the pie chart so
that's how you make a pie chart if you
want you can even add another
argument like the title for example here
i can say that this is a population in
2020
but in this case in percentages so right
this
and now we have this title
so that's how you make a pie chart in
pandas
all right so far we made a pivot table
in many plots using pandas and in this
video we're going to learn how to export
the pivot table and also the plots we
made with pandas so let's start by
exporting the plots we made with pandas
and to do that first we have to import
matplotlib so we write
import matplot
leap
dot pi plot and then we write as plt so
this plt represents this matplotlib dot
pi plot so now we run
and we imported matlab and now we can
use this plt to save the plot so we
write plt
dot save fig
and now we open parenthesis and here we
have to write the name of the file we
want to export and here i'm going to
write my underscore test dot png so this
is the extension and this is the name of
the file and now before exporting this
file i'm going to show you something
here so probably you notice that when we
make the plots with pandas we get these
words here that says access subplot and
all of this
so we can get rid of these words by
using the show method so we write plt
that show with parentheses
and if we run this we're going to export
this figure and also we're going to get
rid of these words so let's try so i run
this and as you can see here all those
words disappeared and also we exported
the figure to a png file and now this
file should be located in the same
folder where you have this jupyter
notebook file okay i'm gonna open that
file but first i'm gonna export the
pivot table so here i copy this df
underscore pivot and i paste it here and
now to export it we have to use that to
excel method so right to underscore
excel
and now i open parenthesis here we write
the name of the file where we're going
to export this pivot table so in this
case i'm going to name it pivot
underscore table dot xlsx
so this is the extension of excel and
this is the name of this file so now i
run this and now the pivot table should
be exported all right now i'm gonna open
the excel file and the png file we
created
so it's here and here we have the plot
we exported and also the pivot table so
as you can see here the plot looks
exactly the same as the one we created
here with pandas and the pivot table is
the same so i'm going to show you how
the pivot table looks and here is the
pivot table in here is the pivot table
we exported i open it in google sheets
and looks exactly the same and that's it
in this video to learn how to support
data frames as well as plots